BRIAN. FOR WEEK. RIGHT I MEAN
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
IS THAT THE OTHER AT THE DATA
THEY HOLD ON THE- PHONE FOR
ABOUT. YEAH BUT- THAT THE GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. WELCOME TO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IT'S A
OBVIOUSLY A CHALLENGING TO MEET
IN CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE
FIND OURSELVES BUT IT ONLY
HAPPENS BECAUSE OF A TERRIFIC
ARMY OF PEOPLE TO GET THIS.
OPERATION ORGANIZED I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO PRO
TEM ATKINS THE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE DEVIN'S CONTRAIRE AS OUR
CHIEF CLERK BERNADETTE MCNULTY
ARE WONDERFUL SERGEANTS TEAM
AND OF COURSE OUR TECHNICAL
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR- WORK AT
THEY'VE DONE TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOW US TO HAVE THIS A MEETING
TODAY AND CERTAINLY THE
CONSULTANTS FROM THE- BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE FOR
THE GREAT WORK IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE.
AVAILABLE TO THEM. SO IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
HAVE TO LIMIT. OUR NONESSENTIAL
GATHER INCIDENT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. CAN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS IT'S ESSENTIAL
THAT THE SENATE HEARING IN THE
SENATE MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THIS SCREEN.
AND OUR ANNOUNCES A RIGHT NOW.
THE EFFORT OF THE NUMBER. IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS FIVE TWO ZERO.
TWO NINE TWO FOUR THAT SHOULD
BE ON YOUR SCREEN FOR THOSE
TWO- TO PARTICIPATE WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT FOR A
PARTICULAR MEASURE A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
IS NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU. AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MY JOB IS THE CHAIR MAINTAIN
IS CUSTOMARY. AND WE ASK A
INDIVIDUALS TO ADHERE TO THE
RULES NOT BE DISRUPTED HIS SO.
I WILL EXERCISE MY RIGHT TO
MEET YOUR CONNECTION. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME. FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE- USE OF NEW
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
S. THAT WE ALL BE RESPECTFUL
IMPATIENT. SO ALL PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. BY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. THE COMMITTEE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THREE ELEVEN BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY. WELL YOU'RE
THOSE BILLS IN ORDER IN WHICH
THEY APPEAR IN THE FILE. AND
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE BILL LET'S FIRST ESTABLISH
A QUORUM FASTER. ACTING
SECRETARY TO THE COMMITTEE TO
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE TURN
YOUR MICROPHONE ON. GLAZER
PRESENT PLEASE ARE PRESENT
CHIANG CARE. NG PRESIDENT
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA PRESIDENT
DODD. DODD PRESIDENT GALGIANI
KALYANI PRESENT HILL PRESIDENT
BELL PRESENT LEYVA YOUR LEYVA
PRESENT PAN HERE. IN PRESENT
WILK PRESIDENT BOOK PRESENT WE
HAVE A QUORUM BREAK A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WILL BEGIN WE'RE GONNA
GO IN FILE ITEM ORDER. CENTER
JONES. WELCOME. SENATOR JOHN
COMES UP LET ME JUST REVIEW THE
PROCESS THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH- FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS WE MIGHT HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT- EACH MEMBER WILL
BE INVITED TO A PRESENT THEIR
BILL BY THEN WILL ASK- THOSE
WHO SUPPORT. THE PROPOSITION TO
COME AND SPEAK AT THE V. THREE
MINUTES ALLOTTED FOR EACH SIDE
TO SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
THERE'S THREE WAYS FOR PEOPLE
TO TESTIFY HERE. IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE ANOTHER HEARING
ROOM. IN THE CAPITOL WHICH WILL
BE A SECOND ALTERNATIVE AND
THEN THE THIRD ALTERNATIVE IS
TELEPHONE. THAT TESTIMONY WILL
DEAL WITH THE SUPPORT SIDE
FIRST IN ALL THREE PLACES. AND
ANY OPPOSITION SIDE IN ALL
THREE PLACES. THAT WE BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. AND
THEN WILL ALLOW THE AUTHOR TO A
CLOSE AND OFFER CLOSING
COMMENTS THAT'S THE PROCESS
THAT WE AS WE GO FORWARD
SENATOR JOHN TO WELCOME AND YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET US
KICKED OFF OF THE WEEK KICKED
OFF EARLY ON A MONDAY MORNING
SO NORMALLY I'D BE ON AN
AIRPLANE. AT THIS TIME A DAY
BUT- BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY. A REALIGNMENT OF
COMMITTEES I GET THAT WE ALL
GET TO BE HERE FIRST THING THIS
MORNING SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THAT AS WELL. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY MONG ALL DCA
BOARDS AND BUREAUS BY REQUIRING
AVERAGE APPLICATION PROCESSING
TIME FRAMES. TO BE EASILY
AVAILABLE TO APPLICANTS ON
THEIR WEBSITE. CURRENTLY ONLY
SOME DC BOARDS IN BUREAUS USE
THE BREEZE LICENSING SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWS APPLICANTS TO CHECK
THE STATUS OF THEIR
APPLICATION. DCA IS NOW RE
EVALUATING WHETHER OR NOT TO
TRANSITION THE REMAINING BOARDS
IN BUREAUS TO BREEZE. IN THE
MEANTIME LICENSE APPLICANTS ARE
LEFT WITH NO RESOURCES. TO FIND
OUT HOW LONG THEY CAN EXPECT TO
WAIT FOR THEIR LICENSE. WITHOUT
THIS SIMPLE INFORMATION
LICENSEES ARE UNABLE TO PLAN
FOR THEIR PROFESSIONAL FUTURE
IN A TIMELY MANNER. GIVEN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC FORECAST
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION TO
APPLICANTS IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS TO GET BACK TO
WORK. SOME BOARDS IN BARRELS
ALREADY DISPLAY THIS
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITE.
ONE BOARD SHARED WITH US AT THE
THEY FIND THAT THE INFORMATION
USEFUL TO THEIR APPLICANTS
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM TO
MONITOR THE TIME FRAMES ON
THEIR OWN. WITHOUT NEEDING A
CONTACT THE BOARD. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT IS SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE VARIETY OF LICENSES
ASSOCIATIONS THAT AGREE. THAT
SHARING THIS INFORMATION WILL
PROVE USEFUL TO APPLICANTS AND
BOARDS ALIKE. AND MISTER CHAIR
I THINK I HAVE WITNESSES ON THE
LINE AND ALSO- LIVE HERE IN THE
ROOM. THANK YOU CENTERS JOHNSON
I UNDERSTAND JENNIFER HILL IS
ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AS SHE AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONE. GERMAN. A JENNIFER TEN
MILLION CARL LONDON MISTER
CHAIR GET. IT ASK A JENNIFER
TEN AND HILL TO BE. AFTER HER
TESTIMONY PLEASE. AB WE DON'T
HEAR FROM JENNIFER LET'S ASK
CONCEIVED CARL LUNDEN IS
AVAILABLE ON THE LINE. HELLO
MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK I CAN'T THANK YOU MISTER
LONDON PLEASE PROCEED. YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL AND
HOPE YOU'RE ALL DOING WELL
THESE DAYS. MY NAME IS CARL
WANTED I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT- WE HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
LICENSING BOARD WHICH HE COULD
DO AN EXCELLENT JOB. IT'S
PROBABLY IS TO HELP YOU GET WE
SHARE IDEAS AND CONCERNS BACK
AND FORTHWITH THEM IT DOESN'T
MEAN WE- SEE EYE TO EYE ON
EVERY ISSUE BUT WE ARE A GREAT.
TALKING RELATIONSHIP ON EVERY
ISSUE ON THIS BILL- WE DO LIKE
OF PREDICTABILITY THIS
LEGISLATION CALLS FOR IF WE
HEAR ANY COMPLETE IT ALL FROM.
MEMBERS IT'S BEEN OBTAINING NEW
LICENSES FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
GRADUATING OR OUT OF. SCHOOL
CARE COAST CAN TAKE A WHILE IN
THE FACTS THE ABILITY. OF
EMPLOYERS TO ON BOARD THEM
SUCCESSFULLY AND SOMETIMES HE
BECOMES DETERMINING FACTOR. IN
HIRING WHEN REALLY QUALITY
SHOULD BE THE MOST FACTOR SO WE
APPRECIATE GAINES BRING THIS
FORWARD AND WE HEARD AND I BOTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LONDON S. A LAST CHANCE FOR MS.
AT TEN AND HILL ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. ARTS CENTER JOHNSON SHE
DOESN'T. APPEAR BEFORE WE
FINISH WILL GIVE HER THAT
CHANCE THANK YOU I WANT TO ASK
OTHERS WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IF THEY ARE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
TO. PLEASE SO INDICATE IN
PLEASE. COME ON UP ONE AT A
TIME TO THE AT THE MICROPHONE.
PLEASE JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND AN INDICATION
OF YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FRANCE BEEN THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA PRETTY ACTIVE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NANCY
KAHLER CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
LICENSE INVESTIGATORS AND
SUPPORT. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
SWITCH THAT AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHERE WE HAVE A PUBLIC
POSITIONS AVAILABLE ANYONE
THERE WHICH IS SIXTY TO COMMENT
AND SUPPORT. WELL I DON'T SEE
ANYONE THERE ARE PRESENT AND
THEN NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. AND ASK IF THE OPERATOR
TO COORDINATE THE- THOSE WHO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SEVEN SIX. I THINK THE
WITH THE MODERATOR WOULD LIKE
TO SAY HERE IS THAT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR TO
PRESS ONE. ZERO AND THAT'LL LET
US KNOW THAT YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OPERATORS
ARE ANYBODY WAITING ON THE LINE.
IS THERE AN OPERATOR MODERATOR
MODERATORS. PLUS THE OPERATOR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. DID YOU WANT
TO TAKE SUPPORT FROM THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME YES THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. OKAY PLEASE
WAIT. I AM NINE TWENTY SIX NOT
THIS BILL. ALRIGHT SO HOLD YOUR
FIRE ON NINE TWENTY SIX WERE
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT BY JOHNSON
NOT ONLY TO IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY I PRAYER.
WHICH BILL ARE WE ON THERE WAS
A- IT'S BEEN- MUTED AND WE
CAN'T HEAR THE PROCEEDING. I
ADDED TO IT I DIDN'T I GOT A
MESSAGE THAT. ALRIGHT SO WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT I THINK NEWARK
DISPUTED THE GENTLEMAN THAT WAS
SPEAKING NEEDED AND SELL FOR.
OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS
IS THE CHAIR WHICH FELLOW WE ON
NOW WE ON SENATOR JERRY HIM
THAT'LL- CALDERON SENATOR JONES
IS BILL EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT. NOW
OKAY I'M I'M WAITING FOR NINETY
SIX YES I'M WAITING FOR NINETY
SIX AS WELL. GOOD OPERATOR
COULD YOU ASK IF ANYBODY'S ON
THE LINE WHICH TO TESTIFY ON SB
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT IN SUPPORT.
SO INDICATE PLEASE. IT. THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS
IS THE COMMITTEE ROOMS. JOHN WE
CAN'T HEAR THE PROCEEDINGS NOW
HIM KNOW. THANK YOU ARE WILL BE
PATIENT HERE'S WE FIGURE THIS
ONE OUT. OPERATOR CAN YOU HEAR
ME. THIS IS SENATOR GLAZER. ALL
FIVE ONE WE DO THIS- AS WE
FIGURE OUT THE TECHNOLOGY THESE
THINGS HAPPEN AS A TO BE
EXPECTED AS ADAM MESSAGE AND
LET HIM KNOW THAT TAKE.
OPERATORS IN YOUR MENU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
YES AT AND T. CAN YOU
HEAR ME THIS IS SENATOR GLAZER
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. YES YOU
SOME UNCLEAR NOW THANK YOU OKAY
TERRIFIC. WE'RE HEARING THAT SB
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT BY JONES AND
WE HAVE THE MOMENT IN OUR-
ASSESS WHERE WE'D LIKE TO ASK
IF THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES IT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT IF YOU COULD ASK THEM TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. WAITED ON
THE FORMALLY AS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINES. I KNOW ONE
IS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
OKAY SO THEN- WE'RE NOT GOING
TO HEAR FROM OPPONENTS OF A SB
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT AND THERE'S
THREE ROOMS IN WHICH THEY COULD
SO INDICATE THEIR OPPOSITION.
THAT WILL START HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IS OR ANYBODY WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION. I SEE NOBODY'S
RAISING THEIR HAND HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WILL GO TO. ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
PRESENT THERE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. NOT SEEN ANYONE SO
INDICATE THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT BY JONES. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COORDINATE THAT.
YES THANK YOU LATER DOWN ON THE
PHONE LINE TO SHOW THEIR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
CENTER JONES I KNOW WE DIDN'T
GET ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT BUT IF IT'S OKAY WITH
YOU WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
MEMBERS. BILLS FOR GENERAL'S
PROGRAM THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
DOES. SENATOR JOHN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR MATTER IS
A BILL I THINK ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM BOTH SIDES THIS IS SHERIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
COMMITTEE THANK YOU AS- WE ALL
WORK OUT THESE EXTRAORDINARY
TECHNICAL ISSUES AYE I THINK
THAT THE DEMEANOR OF THE IS
COMMITTEE IS- SHOWING A GOOD
EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE I WILL SHARE AND THE AND
SENATOR DODD FOR THE- MOTION. I
WILL THIS IS BORN OUT OF A OF A
COUPLE OF INCHES MYSELF AS VICE
CHAIR OF BEING PAEAN ASSEMBLY-
WORKING THROUGH YOUR DCA WITH
SOME OF THESE BREEZE ISSUES AND
THEN PERSONALLY BEING A DC A
LICENSED LICENSEE MYSELF- NINE
NOTICES OTHER LICENSEES ON THE
ON THE DICE AS WELL. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
WITH YOU MEDIAN OF AND THE
BOARDS TO MAKE THIS IS
EFFICIENT POSSIBLE SIDE-
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER JOHNSON A
RECOGNIZE A MOTION FROM CENTER
DODD TO. SAID TO PASS A- THE
APPROPRIATION. THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL NUMBER TEN
ECONOMIC. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
YOU TO PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON- THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASSED YOUR COMMITTEE FOR
SENATE BILLS EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT. MR GLAZER BY THE USER HI
JANE HIGH. PAYING AYE ARCHULETA
HI BUT TO LET AYE DODD. AYE
DODD AYE GALGIANI. GALGIANI AYE
HILL HI L. I. LEYVA. HI LEYVA
AYE PAN HI AND I A WILK. OKAY
SO THE BILL ENJOYS A BOAT SO
WE'RE GONNA PUT IT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR JOHN SERBIAN OUR FIRST
UP THIS EARLY THIS MORNING WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CONSOLATIONS ON YOUR
BILL WILL HOLD THATTHOUGHT
OPEN FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES.
OKAY NEXT RETURN ALL UP A- FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB NINE TWENTY
SIX FIRED SET HEALTH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING AND
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES- SB
NINE TWENTY SIX REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO ACCEPT CASH FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES PURCHASED IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT BANKING
ACCOUNTS OR BANKING
RELATIONSHIPS ARE ABLE TO BUY
BASIC NECESSITIES ACCESSIBILITY
TO SUCH GOODS IS ESPECIALLY
NECESSARY DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. CASH TRANSACTIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO BUY ESSENTIAL
GOODS STATISTICS SHOW 26% OF
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS WERE PAID
FOR IN CASH IN PERSON IN PERSON
PURCHASES TEND TO BE FOR BASIC
NECESSITIES SUCH AS FOOD
CLOTHING AND TOILETRIES.
BUSINESSES THAT DENY CASH AS A
VALID PAYMENT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC ONLY EXACERBATE THE
LACKOF ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
GOODS AND SERVICES FOR UNBANKED
INDIVIDUALSINCLUDING LOW
INCOME HOMELESS AND
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATIONS. SB
NINE TWENTY SIX WILL PROHIBIT
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
FROM DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
CASH PAYMENTS BUSINESSES SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO DENY CASH IS
A VALID PAYMENT METHOD TO
SPECIALLY NOT DURING A PANDEMIC
WHEN ACCESS TO BASIC
NECESSITIES IS GREATLY LIMITED.
AND WHEN MANY OF OUR FRONT LINE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS RELY ON
CASH WAS PAYMENTS OF NINETEEN
AND IT'S AFFECTS FURTHER
ILLUSTRATE THE NEED TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. BY PREVENTING CASH
DISCRIMINATION CALIFORNIA CAN
INSURE ITS ECONOMY IS
ACCESSIBLE AND THAT ALL PEOPLE
CAN BENEFIT FROM AND
PARTICIPATE IN IT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SOME OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
BY STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH AN ALL
OUT WILL TELL YOU SO CAL GAS
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATIC VENDOR COUNCIL ON
FUTURE AMENDMENTS AND I WON
SURE THE ONE THAT- I'M DREAMING
COMP ID. THAT WE PULL A AS
ISSUE THEY HAVE A FIVE FIFTH
FAMILIAR WITH THE IS. HAVE HAD
CONVERSATION WITH THIS TO SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS RELATED TO
THEM AND WE DO HAVE A PATH AND
RESPECTFULLY EFFORT I WILL
MEMBERS AND I HAVE TO WITH.
INSTEAD OF THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL I UNDERSTAND-
YOUR TWO WITNESSES- JESSE GREW
WALL FROM THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS AND JESSICA
BARTH FOLLOW. THROUGH BARTOLO A
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY OPERATOR LIKE TO ASK IF
I YOU COULD IDENTIFY THOSE TWO
WITNESSES AND ALLOW THEM TO- TO
PRESENT THEIR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU I WAS FROZEN FOR A SECOND
WE DO OUR THREE PARTICIPANTS
ALL I'LL JUST TAKE THEM IN
ORDER AND THE FIRST ONE WILL
COME FROM LINE THIRTY EIGHT I
APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU. POINT
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPERATOR I'M NOT. THERE ARE YOU
ARE LYING. BUT I CAN GO AHEAD
EAGLE IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUESTION
THE BARK BUT WOULD LIKE THE
GENERAL MOM ALREADY MISS
BUFFALO THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME TO BEGIN YOU MAY JUST
WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU AND
YOUR THE SECOND. WITNESS IN
SUPPORT I HAVE THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL SO TO KEEP THAT IN MIND
AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU KAREN GLAZER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS JESSICA BARKLOW WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE KIND OF GIRL NINETY SIX AND
APPRECIATED BEING INTRODUCED.
AND YOUR EMAIL AND WE CAN-
RECENT RESEARCH. BY THE FEDERAL
DEPOSIT INSURANCE CORPORATION
SHOW THAT. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF AMERICANS ARE THANK. THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS. TO A BANK
ATM. THEY MAY NOT AND LIKE WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CREDIT
CARDS ARE A FORM. OF NON CASH
PAYMENT. THAT IS. NOT PAYMENT
THAT DO NOT CHARGE THE MONEY.
AT BUYING PREPAID CARDS OR
OTHER NON CASH. SERVICES CAN
YOU CAN COST A LOT OF MONEY IN
THIS MONEY ADDS UP. HELLO
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. UP UNTIL
THE YEAR CALIFORNIANS USING
EVEN JUST A LIKE KIND OF
BENEFIT TRANSFER SYSTEM THE
SYSTEM THAT CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
FOR THEM TO WITHDRAW THEIR CASH
BENEFITS SOONER WHEN OUR LOW
INCOME AND HAVE CHILDREN. WHAT
CHARGING PEOPLE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. PLEASE JUST ON
MONEY- THAT'S MONEY THAT SHOULD
BE USED TO MEET THE BASC NEEDS
OF CHILDREN. WHEN FAMILIES ARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND FOR CASH AS
PAYMENT IT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE
TO TAKE THEIR CASH INCOME
WHETHER IT FROM- AND BEING KIND
OF. A LOW INCOME WORKERS
RECEIVING PAYMENT BY CASH OR
BEING FORCED OUT OF ECONOMY.
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE IMMIGRANT
AND I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ACCEPT A JOB THAT PAID AND NON
CASH PAYMENTS- IT IS TAKES
MONEY FROM THE POCKET. AND
CONNECTS WITH AND WE ARE ASKING
YOU TO CONSIDER THAT THE
LEGISLATION ACCORDING WORKING
WITH SENATOR HILL AND KATHY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO ASK JESSE I AGREE
WALL TO BE THE NEXT SPEAKER IF
YOU COULD BE A COULD OPEN UP.
HER PHONE LINE OPERATOR WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. I REMEMBER CAN
YOU HEAR ME I CAN. HI THIS IS
DEBBIE GRAY ALL WITH UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS I
YEAR HE W. STRONGLY SUPPORT AS
THE NINETEENTH DECORATIVE AN
IMPORTANT BELT THAT ENSURE THAT
ECONOMICALLY UNDERPRIVILEGED
AND YOU CALIFORNIANS ARE THOSE
SIMPLY STRUGGLING STRUGGLING
TEMPORARILY THROUGH HARD TIMES
ARE ABLE TO PAY FOR BASIC
NECESSITIES SUCH AS FOOD
MEDICINE AND CLOTHING AND
TOILETRIES. FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES IF THEY HAVE
MONEY BUT DO NOT HAVE BANK
ACCOUNTS BUT OFTEN REQUIRE
MINIMUM BALANCES ARE CREDIT. AT
THE UNION THAT REPRESENTS
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN THE STATE
THAT THEM THANK YOU FOR THAT
CAN BETTER A STAPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES ABOUT
GROCERY PARK ARE YOU GUYS ARE
LACK ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD AND
BASIC NECESSITIES. AND BANK
HOUSEHOLD OFTEN PROPERTY AND
CONVENIENCE AND CAROL I'M NOT
BEING ABLE TO BUY BASIC
NECESSITIES FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES IT IS YET
ANOTHER PRACTICAL BARRIER THAT
KEEPS WORKING FAMILIES FROM
CLIMB THEIR WAY OUT OF POVERTY
AND IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY-
YOUR GAS THAT DAY. IN COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH. THIS
THIS GROUP ALL YOUR TEST WE'RE
GONNA NOW. BASKETBALL PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO. IN SUPPORT WE'RE
TO GIVE THE THREE OPTIONS HERE
IN THE ROOM WHERE WE ARE NEXT
DOOR AND THEN ON THE PHONE
LINES. SELECT THE ASK THAT YOU
JUST GIVE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. ANYBODY HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION. SEEING NO
HANDS REYES READY GO TO- ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SINGLE
HANDS REYES THERE WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO THE OPERATOR AND ASK IF
THERE'S PEOPLE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWENTY
SIX OPERATOR COULD YOU ASK IF
THERE'S SOME. FOLKS THERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE. TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. ONE AND ZERO
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING SIR
GLAZER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS RYAN KENNY WITH
CLEAN ENERGY- WE ARE A TWEETER
ACTUALLY WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION I WILL ONE OF SEVEN
YOU SIGNED ON TO A LETTER- WITH
SOME CONCERNS. AND BOTH THE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DANCE STATION
BUT DON'T HAVE RETAIL AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING YET FOR COMMITTEE TO
WORK WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION BUT WE THINK THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OPERATOR PLEASE CONTINUE.
WHETHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
UP DISSIDENTS CUED UP IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT THANK
YOU OKAY VERY GOOD NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. I TO SB
NINE TWENTY SIX WILL FIRST GO
TO THOSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE SO INDICATE.
SEEING NO HANDS REYES REALLY GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
THERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO
HANDS REYES THEY'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR TO ASK
IF THERE'S ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION
IT HAS BEEN NINE TWENTY SIX TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE TO YOU. YEAH
YES HI MY NAME IS JASON LAYING
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF CENTER HILL- IN THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO IT TO WORKING
WITH HIM ON THIS MEASURE WE-
CERTAINLY DO NOT QUARREL WITH
THE UNDERLYING POLICY OBJECTIVE
THAT THE MEASURE- WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED. ABOUT THE ASSURANCE
THAT OUR FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
HAVE RELATIVE TO. COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BANK SECRECY ACT IN
MONEY LAUNDERING RULES SO- WE
DO NOT- OBVIOUSLY SELL GOODS-
AND MOSTLY- CONDUCT BUSINESS
WITH CUSTOMERS. THE BILL ITSELF
DOESN'T ACTUALLY MAKE THAT A
NEW ONE- THE DIFFERENTIATION
BETWEEN A CUSTOMER NON CUSTOMER
ROLE TO THE ACCEPTANCE OF
CASTLE CERTAIN TRANSACTIONS
LIKE. EXCHANGING SMALL BILLS
FOR LARGE BILLS ARE EXCHANGING
SMALL BILLS FOR FOREIGN
CURRENCY OFTEN GIVE RISE TO
POTENTIAL MONEY LAUNDERING SO-
WE WANTED TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO IT THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS NEW YORK
THEY HAVE A SPECIFIC FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION CAR ABOUT.
RECOGNIZING SORT OF THE EIGHT
AM ALLEN AND BSA REQUIREMENTS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
CENTER EL. THANK YOU MISTER
LANE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
INDICATE WHETHER THERE'S
ANYBODY OF FURTHER WHICH IS
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION. TO SB.
NINE TWENTY SIX. OPERATOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OPERATOR CAN YOU
HEAR ME THIS IS A COMMITTEE
ROOM. THIS IS JESSICA BARCELONA
I'M ON THE LINE AND I CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY. ALL DOES THANK YOU
JESSICA AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EARLIER TESTIMONY HANG ON THERE
OPERATORS OR ANYBODY ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THIS
LEGISLATION COULD YOU ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON SB NINE TWENTY SIX. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
WE WILL TO LINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE END OF
YOUR CARE THEM BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION I'M NOT
SURE WE WERE PUSHED OVER TO THE
OPPOSE SECTIONS ARE ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS NINE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR HILL. SIR THIS IS THE
SB NINE TWENTY SIX BY HILL IS
AT THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF. THAT IS ORRECT
OKAY AND YOU'VE GIVEN YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING. OPERATOR CAN YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON SB NINE TWENTY SIX
THAT IS NOT DONE SO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
WE'LL GO TO. LINE SIXTY EIGHT.
BY SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YES- HERE TO TESTIFY
FOR SB TEN FIFTY ONE NOT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND LINE TWENTY
SIX IS NOW OPEN. MR KERRY
MEMBERS GENERAL WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY OF THE HELP THAT THEY
CAN HELP BRING AUTOMATIC
VENDORS COUNCIL WERE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO WHAT THE MEN DID AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT YOU MADE A WORKING
WITH WHAT AT THE DEVELOPMENTS
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT NEXT. NEXT WITNESS
OPERATOR PLEASE ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY ON THIS
BILL. LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR TURN
MEMBERS THIS IS MARGARET GLAD
STAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE WE ARE A TWEENER AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU MENDOCINE TAKEN
TODAY AND THE COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON WITH US ON
OUR FINAL ISSUE AND SO- WE HAVE
NO POSITION BUT WE DO THANK YOU
DOCTOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HELP ON. OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS
CLUTCHING OPERATOR IS OR
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD SHE TO
TESTIFY ON THIS LEGISLATION. WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE WILL GO
TO LIKE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS ROBERT WILSON THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION THEY JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS. WILSON WE
LOST CONNECTION LAWYER US.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN SIR
COULD LAST YOU. I WILL GO BACK
TO SIXTY SIX. HELLO MISTER CARE
ROBERT WILSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT MY COLLEGE WITH THE
CALVARY BANKERS ASSOCIATION
BROUGHT UP AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH SENATOR HELL ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU. OPERATORS
ARE ANYBODY ELSE REMAINING TO
TESTIFY ON THIS LEGISLATION. WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN. THERE
WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU FOR
TO THE PAINTING PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR NAME OF ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL. KP
MASTER- OAKLAND PRIVACY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION- WASN'T ABLE TO GET
IN. DURING THAT SESSION THAT.
TINY REGARD IN THANK YOU VERY
MUH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU OPERATORS ANYBODY ELSE
REMAINING ON THE LINE WHICH TO
TESTIFY ON SB NINE TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR HILL. NOT AT THIS
TIME SIR THANK YOU. ARE A VERY
GOOD WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MEMBERS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I'D LIKE TO A-
OFFER UP SOME COMMON CENTER
HILL THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMUNICATION WITH MY STAFF AND
WITH ME AS WE- WORK THROUGH THE
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF SUCH GREAT INTENTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S- IT'S
RIGHT ON THE MARK FOR WHAT WE
WANT TO DO AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS TYPE OF. DISCRIMINATION
DOESN'T EXIST THERE BUT IT
THERE SOME COMPLEXITIES IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION I THINK THAT YOU
HAVE. SO INDICATED THAT YOU'RE
WORKING CONSTRUCTIVELY 'VE
HEARD FROM THOSE. WHO SOME OF
WHOM AT TESTIFIED TODAY THAT
YOU'RE WORKING VERY
CONSTRUCTIVELY WORK OUT THOSE
ISSUES AND SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT YOU
WILL BE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. ANYBODY
ELSE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR HILL FOR A
CLOSING COMMENT SENATOR HILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND FOR
THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD TODAY I
AM- COMMITTED TO CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH AND- RESOLVING THE
REMAINING ISSUES I UNDERSTAND
THEM AND- HAVE LOOKED AT THEM
AND- THEY ARE ALL REASONABLE
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE AND
THERE ARE REASONABLE SOLUTIONS
THAT- WE CAN TAKE- MAKE TO.
ACCOMMODATE THEM- TO RESPECT
FOR YES RELIABLE COLLEGE THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD CENTER HEALTH
THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A MOTION
TO ON THIS LEGISLATION WE HAVE
A- SENATOR LABELS MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU DIDN'T SEE
THAT- AND WITH THAT WILL ASK
THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONE
ON. SENATE BILL NINE TWO SIX
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER BY. WAYS
ARE AYE CHAIN HIGHER PAYING AYE
ARCHULETA HI OR TO LET AYE DODD
AYE. DODD AYE GALGIANI MY GOD
YANNI AYE HILL NIGHT. WELL I
LEYVA. I LEYVA. ALL RIGHT AND I
WILL HI WILK AYE THE MEASURE
HAS NINE BUT BUT THAT MEASURE
IS OUT WITH A NINE TO ZERO VOTE
MODULATION CENTER HILL. WE HAVE
OUR ABSENT MEMBER BACKS WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THE SECRETARY TO-
PULL OFF OF CALL SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT AND CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
REMAINING MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
ONE SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WILK. AYE WILK
AYE THE BILL HAS NOT THAT BILL
IS OUT NINE ZERO. GRADUATION TO
CENTER JONES. PART WITH THAT
NEXT UP WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR MORE LOCK- I FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB TEN FIFTY THREE
CENTER MORLOCK IS PRESENT
WELCOME. BIGELOW FORTY YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU SHAPED YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR THIS BILL
SO MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES GOOD
MORNING. CURRENTLY REGISTERED
NURSES MOVING TO CALIFORNIA.
HAVE TO WAIT SOME NINETY DAYS
TO BE APPROVED BY THE STATE IN
ORDER TO PURSUE THEIR
PROFESSION. THIS IS NOT THE
CASE IN THIRTY FOUR STATES. THE
STATE'S PARTICIPATE IN THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT. SB TEN
FIFTY THREE WOULD HAVE
CALIFORNIA BECOME A MEMBER OF
THIS NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT
THERE ARE MANY ADVANTAGES. TO
THIS PRIVILEGE. IN THE CASE OF
AN EMERGENCY LIKE A SEVERE
EARTHQUAKE NUMEROUS LICENSE
NURSES. FROM THE CURRENT THIRTY
FOUR STATES COULD COME TO
CALIFORNIA TO ASSIST
IMMEDIATELY. THE STANDARDS
MAINTAINED BY THE NURSE
LICENSURE BOARDS ARE FOLLOWED
NATIONALLY AND MEET OR EXCEED
CALIFORNIA'S. CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED NURSES THAT ALSO FLY
TO ONE OF THE THIRTY FOUR
STATES WHEN THEY HAVE A
SHORTAGE. OR AN EMERGENCY. WE
HAVE BECOME A MULTI STATE
NATION FOR MOST INDUSTRIES AND
WITH THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT A
NATIONWIDE APPROACH IS
INEVITABLE. THE THREE ALSO
MODERNIZES THE MEDICAL CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM BY ALLOWING
GREATER ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH
THIS WILL BENEFIT UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF MILITARY SPOUSES
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE SIMPLE
INTERSTATE SOLUTION. KEEPING
INDIVIDUALS EMPLOYED AS
CRITICAL NOW MORE THAN EVER. IT
WILL IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
PARTICIPATING IN THE NETWORK IS
OPTIONAL REGISTERED NURSES CAN
BE CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFIC. AND
IT GIVES CALIFORNIA NURSES MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND FREEDOM IN
DEVELOPING THEIR CAREERS AND
RESUMES. TEMPORARY ASSIGNMENT
SIX MONTHS OR LESS IN OTHER
RECIPROCATING STATES PROVIDESA
BROADER PERSONAL GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY. AND MEETING A
CRITICAL NEED IN A LOCATION
ADDRESSING AN EMERGENCY ALLOWS
FOR EXPANDING A PROFESSIONAL'S
JOB AND PURPOSE SATISFACTION.
IT ALSO PROVIDES ANOTHER WAY
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO DEVELOP
BETTER WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH OTHER STATES. STATES WITH
RESIDENT TO MAY BE SUBSIDIZING.
OUR STATE TO NEED AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR I APPLAUD THE
CONSULTANTS THOROUGHNESS AND
ADDRESSING THE WHAT I WOULD
CALL A MERGER AND ACQUISITION
TYPE OF THE CONCERNS. OF
ADOPTING A NEW RELATIONSHIP. IT
OCCURS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
TO. HOWEVER I KEPT A
DISAGREEMENT WITH SOME OF THE
REPORTS OBSERVATIONS BUT
BECAUSE OF LIMITED TIME I WILL
GO THROUGH THEM ONE BY ONE.
NONE OF THE ISSUES RAISED
HOWEVER ARE INSURMOUNTABLE.
THIS IS OPTIONAL SO THE AREAS
FOR CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE CAN BE
ADDRESSED BY CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS NOT ADOPTING IN. IN
OTHER AREAS I'M SURE OUR STATE
ADMINISTRATORS ARE UP TO THE
CHALLENGE OF INTEGRATING WITH
THE COALITION OF INTERSTATE
LIKE MINDED PROFESSIONALS. OUT
OF THEIR INDUSTRY AND THEIR
ROLES IN IT. I BELIEVE THE
COMPACT WILL IMPROVE THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING. AND HE
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY PARTICIPATES
IN A NUMBER OF INTERSTATE
COMMISSIONS. AND MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES. AKA FARGE
THE DIRECTOR OF STATE ADVOCACY
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS. AT THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING. AND GARY
COOPER REPRESENTING AM IN
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MORE LOCK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IT'S GOING TO INVITE-
THAT REBEKAH FORCED TO BE THE
FIRST PERSON TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
THE BILL I WOULD NOTE TO HER
AND TO MISTER COOPER THAT YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL SO
HOPEFULLY OF COORDINATED YOUR
TESTIMONY TOGETHER OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK. OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR A BACKUP FOR THE POSH.
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD BECCA.
HI HI MY NAME IS REBECCA FIVE
JOHN WITH THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
OF STATE BOARDS OF NURSING- AND
WE WERE THE DRAFTERS OF THAT
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT
LANGUAGE AT THE SENATOR STATED
THAT THE COMPACT- ESSENTIALLY
FUNCTIONS LIKE EIGHT AMADOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND MATCH A
NURSE HAS A LICENSE AND THAT
STATE THAT HERE SHE RESIDES AND
THEN USES THAT LICENSE TO
PRACTICE AND ANY OF THE OTHER
THIRTY FOR CONTACT STATE
WITHOUT HAVING TO GET REAL LIFE
AND- AND THE REASON THAT THAT
WORKS SO WELL FOR NURSE
LICENSURE A BATCH GENERALLY
NURSE. NURSING LICENSE- IT'S
PRETTY STANDARD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- ERR THE EDUCATION IS
STANDARD- EVERY NURSE BUT TAKE
THE AND CRACKS BEFORE SHE CAN
GET HER LIFE IN CHURCH AND
BECAUSE OF THAT UNIFORMITY IT
REALLY LENDS ITSELF TO A
COMPACT- AND THEN THE CONTACT
AND ALSO IT IT ONE OF THE MAIN
FOCUSES ON PATIENT SAFETY BOARD
OF NURSING ARE JOINING THIS
COMPACT AND THEIR CONCERN IS
PATIENT SAFETY SO THEY'RE IN
THE CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK
REQUIREMENTS. AND IT REQUIRED.
UNDER A LOOK ARE REQUIRE I'M
SHARING OF IN. SO TO MAKE SURE
THAT I AFTER THAT EVERYONE
STATE STATE AND THE COP. I
THINK I'LL STOP THERE SO THAT
GARY HAD BEEN TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINE FOR MR COOPER
PLEASE. IF YOU PREFER YOU A
CLIENT AT TEN FORTY SAID SERVE
ANY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GARY COOPER- REPRESENTING A
MANY HEALTH CARE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT TEN FIFTY
THREE- AS SOME OF YOU KNOW A
AND THEN JOINTLY HEADQUARTERED
IN SAN DIEGO AND IS THE LARGEST
MOST INNOVATIVE HEALTHCARE
STAFFING COMPANY IN THE
COUNTRY. AND THEY EMPLOYED
DEPLOYED THOUSANDS OF HIGHLY
QUALIFIED LIKE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS TO HOSPITALS
EVERY WEEK. UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS NOT A
MEMBER OF THE CONTACT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DEPLOY- SAPPING
THEY HAD A EMPLOYEES TO THE
DIFFERENT STATE BUT THE THIRTY
FOUR MEMBER STATES THAT ARE.
PART OF THE CONTACT HAVE BEEN
DOING A WHOLE LOT EASIER. PRIOR
TO THE CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS
CALIFORNIA SHORTAGE OF NURSES
HAS BEEN ENORMOUS CONCERN AND
PARTICULARLY THE PROBLEM IS IT
TAKES FOREVER TO GET THEM
LICENSED. CAN FIFTY THREE WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL IN LEADING THAT
PROBLEM. AFTER THE COLBERT
NINETEEN CRISIS TO CALL UNITED
STATES. DEMAND FOR NURSES
RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS ARGUE
CALIFORNIA NEW YORK AND THE
PAST TWO MONTHS AND THEN WITH
ITS PARTNERS WERE ABLE TO THE
PLIGHT TEN THOUSAND HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. THANK YOU SEEN AS
CRISIS WORSENED MACHINE
GOVERNOR'S PLEAD FOR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS TO COME TO THEIR STATES
PARTICULARLY IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN NEW YORK AND BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA WAS NOT A MEMBER OF
THE CONTACT. WE HAD TO GET
EMERGENCY ORDERS TO GET THOSE
LICENSURE MADE LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS WAIT AND HOUR VERY
CONCERNED THAT THE LICENSURE
WAIVER. THE OUR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS GOING TO A- PRETTY SOON
AND WE'RE SURE WHETHER I NOT
THOSE MUCH NEEDED HEALTHCARE.
WILL BE ABLE TO STAY. IN THE
STATE. EVEN AFTER THE PANDEMIC
THE POT. INSIDE THE NURSING
SHORTAGES WALKING TO GROW AND
THE STRAIN ON THE HEALTH SYSTEM
ONLY GET WORSE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING PATIENT CARE IF WE
CAN FACILITATE MORE AND
EXPEDITE THE PLACEMENT OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THAT WOULD
BE A TREMENDOUS BLOOM AND TO
HELP THE PATIENT THE CALIFORNIA
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON IT SB
TEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU SO
MUCH- GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER COOPER WE'RE GOING TO
NOW OFFER UP AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION TO SO
INDICATE. BY GIVING THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
INDICATION OF SUPPORT FOR THE
THREE PLACES IN WHICH WE ACCEPT
TESTIMONY TODAY HERE IN THE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE. COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. RIGHT NOW ALL.
NETWORK A DIVISION OF CHEN IN
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THE NOTE FOR THEIR
HANDS ALL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I SEE NO
HANDS THERE WERE GOING TO GO TO
THE OPERATOR AND ASK OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN ASK IFTHERE'S
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY THREE BY CENTER
MORE LOCKED TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
ON TEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE
WILL OPEN UP LINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE ON
YOUR PHONE SEVENTY ONE. BUT
WILL BE ALIGNED SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JANICE WHO
IN ALL RIGHT I'M SPEAKING AS CO
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPENDS
COMMUNITIES ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING THE FRENCH
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS CHAIRMAN OF THE BE
ALL MILITARY LIAISON COUNSEL.
PICKING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR FINGER IN
LINE. THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVENTY FIVE IS YOUR
LINE MUTED. PLEASE TELL ME YOUR
PHONE LINE SEVENTY FIVE. MOVING
ALONG OVER LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HELLO AS WE CAN YES WE CAN'T
PLEASE A YOUR NAME AT THE
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR INDICATION
OF SUPPORT ON THIS LEGISLATION.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON GOLD FAR
BEHIND DEAN OF HEALTH SCIENCES
THE COLLEGE OF MARIN I'M ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION OF ASSOCIATE
DEGREE. NURSING NORTH AND I AM
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OPERATOR IF YOU GO TO
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ORDER LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MR
KERRY MEMBERS. OVER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN COURT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HIS LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY ONE
PLEASE TELL ME YOUR PHONE
THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. MOVING
ALONG WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. READ ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
IMPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WINE SEVENTY SIX YOU
ARE NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMY BLOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISS VAUGHN
BURKE NEXT. FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SANDY
PERSON REPRESENTED THE TRAVIS
COMMUNITY CONSORTIUM WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER LINES THANK YOU
LIFE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KHAN
NAME I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT OPERATOR. LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES.
ONE EIGHTY ONE ON YOUR PHONE
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY ONE ONE
MORE CHANCE. WE WILL LINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE NOW
OPEN. WE CAN'T HEAR YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THEY ARE NOT
RESPONDING THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO TO
OPPONENTS OF THIS LEGISLATION
AND GIVE THEM THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY- THIS
IS- SB TEN FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR MORE LOCKER THERE
ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN IN THE ROOM.
I SEE A HAND IN THE BACK SO
PLEASE COME ON OUT. THE MORNING
I'M DONNA HARRIS REPRESENTING
THE BORDER REGISTERED NURSING.
WE REPRESENT A PROXY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. RECENTLY
RECOMMENDED TO THE FULL BOARD
WHICH WILL MEET THE END OF THIS
MONTH. TO OPPOSE SENATE BILL
TEN FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS HARRIS AND I AM ASK A
QUESTION IN A MOMENT THAT WILL
ASK FINISH WITH THE OTHERS
TESTIFYING AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
COME BACK UP. TO ANYBODY ELSE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO HANDS ARE
GONNA GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE THERE. SEEING NO HANDS
REYES WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR CAN YOU
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SB TEN FIFTY THREE TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY TWO ZERO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT WE
DO HAVE A PARTICIPANT QUEUING
UP. AND WE WERE LINE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CHORUS LINE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION SEEING AS
OPPOSED TO SB TEN FIFTY THREE
IN IMPLEMENTATION OF NURSE
NURSE LICENSE COMPACT JOIN THE
NURSE LICENSING COMPACT
UNDERMINE PUBLIC SAFETY BY AND
HE WOULD CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
TO SET STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO
ALL NURSES PARTICIPATING IN THE
STATE. WE STICKING CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO REQUIRE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR HAVING
CALIFORNIA FROM KNOWING WHO IS
PRACTICING IN THE STATE AT ANY
GIVEN TIME DURING THE CONTACTED
ME THE NURSES WILL BE HELD TO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS DESPITE
WORKING THE SAME STATE THE
CALIFORNIA JOIN THE COMPACT
NURSES FROM COLORADO WOULD BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE HERE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO ENGAGE IN ANY
CONTINUING EDUCATION AT ALL.
AND IF LICENSE BEFORE BUT
DOESN'T FIFTEEN ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO UNDERGO A
BACKGROUND CHECK OR SUBMIT
FINGERPRINTS TO THE DOJ.
CONTRARY TO THE TO THE
INTENTION OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION DO I KNOW WHAT
NURSING LICENSE FOR COMPACT
WILL HAVE THE EFFECT OF
REDUCING ACCESS TO THE NURSING
PROFESSION FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. LIBERATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY IN ORDER TO WIN THE
COMPACT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
REQUIRED TO ENACT THE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN ALSO YOU
KNOW THE MODEL LEGISLATION
WHICH THAT SPECIFY SPECIFIC ALL
PUBLICATION. STANDARDS FOR
NURSING. LICENSE EDUCATION THE
MODEL INDICATES THAT AND FOR
NAPA TO OBTAIN A MULTI LIFE SHE
MUST HAVE MORE BOARD GROUP ARE
AND LICENSES PRO BUT THIS MAY
SEEM AN ODD WITH KEY WORD HERE
AS GRADUATE CALL TURNED ROUTE
TO LICENSE ARE DISCUSSED ABOVE
INCLUDED THIRTY UNIT L. B. AND
ARE AN OPTION IN THE MILITARY
EXPERIENCE OPTION AND THEY ARE
NON GRADUATE PROGRAMS NURSES
WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
ROUTES TO LICENSOR HAVE NOT
GRADUATE SMALL BORE PREMPRO
PROGRAM AND SO THEY WOULD BE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR LICENSURE UNDER
THE CONTACT. ALSO EVASION AT
WITH THIS DOESN'T THAT ADOPTION
OF THE YOU KNOW SEE THIS NOT
ACTUALLY MAKE NURSES MORE
MOBILE. COMPACT LICENSOR DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR COMPLETELY
UNENCUMBERED MOVEMENT ACROSS
STATE LINES THEN THEY'LL SEE
PERMITS A NURSE TO HOLD ONLY
ONE ACTIVE COMPACT LIKES AND AT
A TIME IN HER PRIMARY STATE OR
WAS AND- FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE JOURNAL BOOK TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATIVE QUEUE ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB TEN
FIFTY THREE PLEASE. TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO TEN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS KURT BLACK PRINT
ON THE AFTER UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATIONS OF CALIFORNIA YEAR
BACK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER OPERATOR.
I KNOW THE PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE WERE
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
COULD HEAR YOUR YOUR TO TESTIFY
ON SB TEN FIFTY THREE. I AM I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE OKAY IF YOU
COULD JUST HAVE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION ALL YET IN YOUR
WORKERS ON THE BILL. MY NAME IS
JOY CAPTION BEIN HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE A RP AND IT'S THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING YOUR TESTIMONY
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY ON SB TEN
FIFTY THREE COULD YOU ASK HIM
TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. PLEASE
INDICATE BY PRESSING ONE ZERO.
WE DO A ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT. ONLY LITTLE LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE ON MUTE. HI I WOULD BE
GIVEN A- LINE I'M NOT SURE IF
MY LINE OR NOT BUT THIS IS
DANIEL REALITY WITH FIND YOUR
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OPERATORS ANYBODY FURTHER
WISHES TO TESTIFY ON THIS
LEGISLATION. WE HAVE ONE LINE
ADELINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I LEAVING ONLY THAT P.
DOCKING AT WORK WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ALL. NO WAY
THEIR PART WHAT'S WE DO SCOTT
ONE ANOTHER ONE AND WE'LL GO TO
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TAMMY DALY AND
HEALTH CARE AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OPERATOR ANY ANYBODY
FURTHER ON THE LINES. NOT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR EVERYONE'S PATIENCE ON
THAT- WE'D LIKE TO BRING THE
MATTER NOW BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MEMBERS I HAVE CENTER
LEYVA. SENATOR PAN SENATOR
HEALTH CENTER LEYVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS YOUR FIRST OUR
WITNESS SENATOR MORLOCKS SAID
THAT LICENSURE IS PRETTY
STANDARD ACROSS THE STATE. BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE FROM THE
OPPOSITION'S OF TESTIMONY THAT
IN OTHER STATES. YOU HAVE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GRADUATE FROM A
BOARD APPROVED PROGRAM SO I WAS
JUST HOPING SOMEONE COULD GIVE
ME A LITTLE CLARIFICATION THANK
YOU CENTER LEYVA- MISTER CHAIR
IS REBEKAH FOX STILL ON THE
LINE. CLUTCH CITY HERE THE
QUESTION FOR THE CENTER LEYVA.
I DID OKAY. YOU'RE WELCOME TO
RESPOND. YEAH SO I'M IS PRETTY
STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- WHAT THE OPPOSITION
WAS REFERRING TO IS SOME STATES
AND HAVE. A CERTAIN PASSION TO
OUR GRADUATING FROM NURSING
SCHOOL IN ORDER TO GET A
LICENSE ON THIS COULD BE OUR
MAYBE IF IT WAS A FORMER
MILITARY AND THEN THEY ARE ABLE
TO USE SOME OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL WORK FOR MILITARY
TO TRANSITION INTO A- EITHER-
ALBION NO OR A NURSE IN THAT
WAY SO THERE ARE SOME- SOME
DIFFERENT IN THAT RESPECT- BUT
IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THAT HAS NO BEARING ON THE
CONTACT YOU. IF REQUIRING IT'S
ALLOW DIFFERENT OUR- TO LIGHT
GINGER THAT WE REMAIN NOTHING
WHICH THAT. IT'S JUST THAT
THOSE HER WHO DO HAVE NOT
GRADUATED PROMOTE- BORDER
TROOPS NURSING PROGRAM. IN
SCHOOL. IS ONE OF ELIGIBLE FOR
A MULTI STATE LICENSE THEY'RE
STILL ELIGIBLE I WOULD ASSUME
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE IT
WOULDN'T CHANGE THEIR CURRENT
STATUS AT ALL IT'S JUST THAT
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
MULTI STATE LICENSE AND THE
PURPOSE FROM THAT GROUP FOR
THAT IS THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN THAT RICH BACK.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THERE
COULD BE EVEN MORE CHANGES IN
THE FUTURE SO IN A CONTACT YOU
IF THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF THE STATE CAN FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT YOU KNOW AT THE
MINIMUM EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
THE NURSES HAVE GRADUATED FROM-
AN APPROVED NURSING SCHOOL. SO
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT SO IF
YOU'RE AYE GRADUATE IF I DO NOT
GRADUATE FROM A BOARD APPROVED
PROGRAM I CURRENT WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO HAVE A MULTI STATE
STATE SINCE. CORRECT YOU WOULD
JUST HAVE IF YOU WERE A
CALIFORNIA- DID IT THEN YOU
WOULD JUST BE OUT I'LL DOUBLE
FOR A CALIFORNIA LICENSE NOT
HAVE BE MULTI DAY PRIVILEGE AS
CRACK SO OTHER AND NURSES IN
OTHER STATES WHO DON'T GRADUATE
FROM ABOARD APPROVED PROGRAM.
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO BE A
PART OF THIS COMPACT IF
CALIFORNIA WERE TO APPROVE THIS.
RIGHT IT IT IT IS THE SAME FOR
ANY STATE SO. WHAT DAY I AND
I'M I DON'T KNOW THAT BUT LET'S
SAY THAT TAXES- ALLOW. NURSES
WHO HAVE. I DON'T EVEN KNOW I
ANSWER SOMETIMES THERE ARE
PROGRAMS SO THAT A BIRD I'LL BE
AND TO BE CALM AND- ARE AND BUT
PERHAPS THEY HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
GRADUATED FROM NURSING SCHOOL
IN ORDER TO DO THAT I CAN'T
THINK OF ANOTHER EXAMPLE OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT IT IS
APPLIED CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO EVERY NURSE THAT
CURRENT THAT HAS A MULTI STATE
LICENSE HAVE YOU HAVE HAD
GRADUATED FROM A BORDER TROOPS
NURSING PROGRAM I NURSING
SCHOOL. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BYE MISTER MODERATOR COULD
I HEAR FROM OPPOSITION IF THEY
FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT THAT.
MISTER CHAIR I GUESS I SHOULD
ASK YOU I'M SORRY THE OPERATOR
WE HAD THAT TO INTO THAT WE HAD
THE TWO WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION FROM THE- THE-
NURSING ASSOCIATION CAN YOU ASK
IF THEY'RE STILL ON THE LINE I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THEM TO
COME BACK IN AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL. RESPONSES TO CENTER
LEYVA. IS THERE LINES AT. THAT
LISTED AS A CO HOST JUST I
DON'T BELIEVE SO- CENTER
LEVERAGE YOUR CALL THEIR NAMES
IT DON'T I APOLOGIZE. ON
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE REPRESENTING THE
NURSES- UNION ON THE LINE IF
YOU DID IT THEY THEY GET SO
INDICATE SO WE COULD INVITE
THEM TO RESPOND. OKAY ANYBODY
FOR ME THE NURSES ASSOCIATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE WERE
LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATOR LABOR- YES SO YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE SIR
YES MY NAME IS CURTIS LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION SO DOES MENTION
BEFORE WITH REGARDS TO
EDUCATION AND- THE MODEL
LEGISLATION DICTATE THAT IN
ORDER FOR APPLICANT TO OBTAIN A
MULTI STATE LICENSE YOU MUST
HAVE GRADUATED FROM A BOARD
APPROVED ARE IN PRE LICENSE OR
EDUCATION PROGRAM. AND SO THAT
MEANS THE ALTERNATIVE ROUTE
SELECTION SIR THAT WE'VE JUST
BEEN DISCUSSING MILITARY OR THE
THIRTY UNITS HEALTHY AND ARE AN
OPTION AND THE MILITARY
EXPERIENCE PERRANCE OPTION
THOSE ARE NON GRADUATE PROGRAMS
SO NURSES WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE ROUTES TO LICENSOR HAVE
NOT GRADUATED FROM BOARD
APPROVED PROGRAM AND SO THEY
WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
LICENSE UNDER THE CONTACT.
THANK YOU. A ONE LAST DID I
HEAR ON A YOU SENATOR MORLOCKS
SAY THAT THEY WERE THIRTY FOUR
STATES THAT ARE PART OF THE
COMPACT NOW. OKAY THANK YOU NO
MORE QUESTIONS MISTER JACK
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA IT WILL
GO TO SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU A-
CHAIR- QUESTION- IN TERMS OF IF
SO IF CALIFORNIA JOINS THE
COMPACT AND THERE IS A NURSE TO
IS AN AND OTHERS HE WAS I GUESS
ORIGINALLY ISIS AND OTHER STATE
IN THE CONTACT AND
UNFORTUNATELY IS. HAS TO BE
DISCIPLINED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS THE NURSE LOSE
HER LICENSE COULD BE HIM HER
HAND LICENSE ACROSS THE WHOLE
CONTACT JUST CALIFORNIA OR CAN
CALIFORNIA NINE ACT ON THIS SO
WHAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN TERMS OF
DISCIPLINARY OVERSIGHT OVER
ANYONE PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA
SO THEIR LICENSE IN COLORADO
UNDER THE CONTACT AND THE NOW
PRACTICING CALIFORNIA CAN
CALIFORNIA SANCTION THAT NURSE
SO THEY HAVE TO WAIT YOU HAVE
TO GO TO CALIFORNIA TO COLORADO
TO HAVE THEM SANCTIONED. THANK
YOU CENTER PAN MR FOR MASS IF
MISS FIGHTS COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. ARE NOT. OPERATIVE
YOU CAN ASK MR A BUNCH TO OPEN
UP A PHONE LINE TO SHE COULD
RESPOND TO SENATOR PANTS
QUESTION. YEAH ON YEAH I'M HERE
THANKS THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- SO THE WAY THAT
DISCIPLINE WORKS AND THE
CONTACT IS THE STATE WHERE THE
NURSE IS A LIFE SENTENCE SO
WE'LL USE THAT COLORADO
CALIFORNIA EXAMPLE I'M SO IN
THE STATE OF COLORADO IS THE
ONLY STATE THAT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THAT NURSES
LIFE SENTENCE- BECAUSE THEY
ARE. THE STATE THAT GRANTED
THAT LICENSE SO THEY ARE THE
ONLY ONES THAT COULD REVOKE THE
LICENSES FUND THE LICENSE OR
DISCIPLINE THAT LICENSE- IF
THEY DO DO THAT IF IT IS THAT
THE PLAN THAT BàN BE
PRIVILEGES. HAVE PRACTICE AND
ANY CONTACT STATE FOR THAT
NURSES ARE DISBANDED UNTIL THE
DISCIPLINE HAS BANNED- HAD
ENDED. NOW THAT BEING SAD IF
THAT COLORADO NURSES PRACTICING
AND CALIFORNIA AND THERE THE
HARM THAT HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA IS ABLE
TO STILL DISCIPLINE THE NURSE
AND THE SENSE THAT CALIFORNIA
HOPE THAT NURSES. WE CALL
PRIVILEGED PRACTICE BUT IT'S
BETTER YOU REALLY NEED TO
PRACTICE. IN CALIFORNIA SO
LET'S USE AN EXAMPLE LET'S SAY
THAT THAT NURSES- DIVERTING
MEDICATION. SO IF CALIFORNIA IF
IT CALIFORNIA FIND THAT THAT
HAD IVERTED MEDICATION BAY CAN
BAND AND CALIFORNIA CAN CHOOSE
TO. AB IN A COULD YOU COULD NOT
ACT- LOOK MORE THE MOST LIKELY
IT WHAT IN IT COULD SHOOT TO
THE SPEND- BAT PRIVILEGE TO
PRACTICE AWHILE MAYBE THAT
NURSE JUST A THOUGHT THE NEW
BUDGET. I SOMETHING TO BE A
PROGRAM OR HELP COULD REVOKE
THAT PRIVILEGE ONE CALIFORNIA
WHEN THAT'S GOING ON THAT
INVESTIGATIVE PHASE IN MY
CALIFORNIA'S DISCIPLINING THE
COLUMN RIGHT A NURSE CALIFORNIA
HAS TO COMMUNICATE THAT
INFORMATION TO COLORADO BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE NURSES
ORIGINALLY LIKE. THAT
COLORADO'S BANG USE THE
INFORMATION FROM CALIFORNIA AND
DISCIPLINE THE NURSES LICENSED.
SO MAYBE COLORADO. IT ALSO SAYS
THAT THE LIGHTS BASE ON WHAT
HAPPENED AND CAL. BUT BACK
SHARE INFORMATION SHARING IS A
REQUIREMENT OF THE COMPACT. AND
AGAIN WHEN CALL IF COLORADO AND
DID IT IF THE PLAN THE NURSE
BASED ON CALIFORNIA'S-
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS ABOUT
CALL THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CASES- BAND
WHILE THAT NURSES UNDER THAT
THE PLAN HER PRIVILEGES TO
PRACTICE AND- ANY OF THE STATES
WOULD BE SUSPENDED. SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE DYNAMIC BETWEEN IF
YOU'RE A STATE THAT ISSUE THE
LIGHTS AND THE OR IF YOU'RE THE
STATE WHERE THAT NURSES
PRACTICING. WELL I GUESS I'D
SAY IS I MEAN I THINK THERE ARE
A LOT OF ISSUES- THINGS ARE OUT
OF AN ANALYSIS THAT- NEED TO BE
EXAMINED I THINK DISCIPLINE
CERTAINLY IS ONE OF THOSE IN
TERMS OF CALIFORNIA BEING ABLE
TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
PRACTICE IN THE STATE. AND TO
BE DEPENDENT ON OF OTHER
LICENSING BOARD EXHIBIT
CONCERNING AND I THINK NEEDS
MUCH FURTHER EXAMINATION AS
WELL AS MANY OTHER ISSUES I
THINK THAT WERE RAISED A- IN
THE TESTIMONY. SO EIGHT NO WE
HAVE A PROCESS HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE- LEAD BUYER CHAIR AND
ALSO THAT BOTH YOU AND SEND AND
ASSEMBLY AND TERMS OF REVIEWING
THE VARIOUS BOARDS AND SO
FORTH- WHAT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW THIS BILL
BEING PRESENTED TODAY AT EIGHT
THANK YOU. THIS NEEDS TO BE A
MUCH MORE. THOUGHT OUT AND
CAREFULLY REVIEWED PROPOSAL AND
I DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT. THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
A SERVICE WHERE YOU TALK ABOUT
NATIONALIZING- YEAH. THE POWER
TO LICENSES THAT GRANT TO THE
STATE THAT'S UNDER THE TENTH
AMENDMENT THE CONSTITUTION- AND
I THINK THAT- WE NEED HONOR
THAT. AND SO- AT THIS POINT
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK IT
NEEDS MUCH FURTHER WORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
CENTER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- THANK YOU YOU'VE
ANSWERED. MY QUESTIONS THAT-
OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE- **** BUT
I JUST WANTED TO. THIS TO MAKE
A LITTLE COMMENT I THINK IS
USE. INDICATED IN YOUR FIRST
STATEMENT THAT THERE ARE MANY
ADVANTAGES TO THIS AND I THINK
THERE COULD BE AND IT THERE ARE
POTENTIAL. ADVANTAGES FOR OF
FOR CALIFORNIA BUT IN LOOKING
AT THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACED WITH THE LEGISLATION. AND
MOVING TO A- A COMPACT- WITH
OTHER STATES FOR OUR- BE AND
SO. I THINK WE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE WOULD BE DIFFERENT
TO THE- LOWEST COMMON
DENOMINATOR AND CALIFORNIA.
PRIDES ITSELF ON THE TREMENDOUS
HEALTH CARE WE HAVE AND
CERTAINLY OUR ENGINE. AND A LV
ENDS ARE OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY
AND- I THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE STANDARDS THAT WE SET AND
THE BOARDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
REGULATIONS THAT WE APPLY. SO I
WOULD JUST BE FEARFUL THAT WE
WOULD BE GOING DOWN TO. THE
SLOPE BUT AT THIS POINT WITHOUT
THE SAFEGUARDS IT COULD BE A IN
THE LEGISLATION SO
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL BE ABLE
TO. SUPPORT IT UP TODAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER HELL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE IS TERRACE
FROM THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING TO COME BACK UP. THE
STAIRS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WAS SHORT. I
WANT TO ASK YOU A FEW FOLLOW
UPS- SO THERE'S BEEN SOME.
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE
DELAYS THAT IT TAKES FOR A
SOMEONE WHO'S A PERSON ANOTHER
STATE TO COME HERE AND PRACTICE
COULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. CAN ABOUT. THE VERY.
OF THE- FOR A PERSON COMING IN
FROM ANOTHER STATE- WE DO HAVE
A PROCESS IN PLACE THAT TAKES
APPROXIMATELY TEN WEEKS. TO
VERIFY THAT LICENSEES THAT ARE
COMING IN FROM OTHER STATES AND
ONE OF THE REASONS OUR PROCESS
IS THE WAY TO DO THIS IS
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. IT
IS NOT JUST AN EASY CHECK LIST.
OF SHOWING UP IN FILLING OUT AN
APPLICATION SENDING IN THE
MONEY AND THEN IT'S DOUBT. SO
OUR PROCESS IS LENGTHY ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE STANDARDS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE QUALITY. IS KEPT
AT THE LEVEL THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
THIS TERRACE. THE IT THE
ANALYSIS INDICATES THAT TO BE A-
REGISTERED NURSE WITHIN THE
CONTACT THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH HOW MANY RED
NURSES THAT WE HAVE LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT DO NOT
HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
I AM NOT FAMILIAR AS FAR AS THE
EXACT NUMBER BUT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS REQUIRED IN
CALIFORNIA YES. THAT IS NOT
REQUIRED OR IS REQUIRED IS
REQUIRED IN CALIFORNIA IS YES.
US AT THAT THE YOU CAN'T USE A
FEDERAL ID NUMBER. NOW IN PLACE
OKAY AND- LASTLY CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THE ISSUE OF STANDARD SO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL WHAT IS
IT THAT WE ARE TRYING TO-
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR VERIFY WHEN
YOU DO A REVIEW OF A NURSE
WHO'S BEEN LICENSE ANOTHER
STATEWIDE TO TAKE TEN WEEKS
WHAT AND WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR EXACTLY THE REASON THAT IT
TAKES TEN WEEKS IS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE REQUIRE FIRST OF
FOUR MONTHS WE REQUIRE THAT THE
NURSE SUBMIT TRANSCRIPTS. THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
COME FROM THE INSTITUTION IN
OTHER STATES THE NURSE CAN JUST
SEND THOSE TRANSCRIPTS AND TO
THE BOARD THAT IS APPROVING
THEIR LICENSURE WE WANT THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS TO COME FROM THE
STATE OR SOME FOR US OTHER%
COUNTRIES FROM THE INSTITUTIONS
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
FRAUD WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FRAUD THAT IS DEALT
WITH WITHIN OUR BOARD RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO COME INTO
CALIFORNIA PRACTICE. AND IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
THE CONSUMERS SO IT DOES TAKE A
LONG TIME WE HAVE TO HAVE
TRANSCRIPTS WE ALSO REQUIRE
FINGERPRINTS THOSE FINGERPRINTS
ARE NOT SHEARED FROM THE STATE
BECAUSE THE EARLY DONE AND SO
THIS TAKES- LET THE TIME TO GET
ALL OF THIS CRISIS DONE IN
PLACE AGAIN I SHOWING THAT THE
QUALITY OF THE STANDARDS ARE
HIGH OTHER STATES BUT THE
REASON DO NOT COMPLICATED. BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING. THE FINAL
MISTER YOU SPEAK TO THAT OF
NURSE SHORTAGES REFERRED LAW OF
CALM ARE MANY COMMENTARY. I
KNOW THE ANALYSIS RAPPER SOME.
STATISTICS IN THAT. CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF ARE WE I
BALANCE IN CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF NURSES GOING TO OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS LICENSE AND PRACTICING
HERE VERSUS WHAT THE NEED IS.
YES THIRTY GLAZER THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT QUESTION I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK NOT
ONLY AMONGST US HERE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE AMONGST YOU WITHIN
A LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO. WITHIN
THE MEDIA IN REFERENCE TO
NURSING SHORTAGES THERE ARE
NURSING SHORTAGES IN SPECIFIC
REGIONS ARE CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE NOT NURSING SHORTAGES IN
AREAS SUCH AS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE FORECAST THE
HAS BEEN GIVEN TO US FROM ARE
YOU SEE S. F. RESEARCHERS SHOWS
THAT THERE WOULD BE AN OVER
ABUNDANCE OF LICENSE REGISTERED
NURSES. IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
SO THERE ARE REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES SOME OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE SEE THE SHORTAGES ARE
IN THE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE THE
WORLD- NURSING. BUT THAT HAS
NOTHING TO DO SPECIFICALLY WITH
US DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT
NURSING SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE NURSES THAT
USUALLY STATE. WITHIN FIFTY
MILES OR SO ON THE PLACES THAT
THE GRADUATE WHAT THAT HAS TO
DO IS WITH THE INSTITUTIONS
BEING ABLE TO RECRUIT NURSES.
TO COME AND LIVE IN TO SOME OF
THOSE AREAS. WHEN YOU SEE A
SERVICE THAT SAME SHORT IN THE
THOSE ISOLATE AREAS APPLY TO
OTHER AREAS OF HEALTHCARE.
POSITIONS FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE-
IS THAT THE- SAME TYPE OF AN
ISSUE IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH DOCTORS IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH DOCTORS IN
CERTAIN PLACES A CALIFORNIA.
ABSOLUTELY I WOULDN'T TRY TO
SPEAK FROM THE DOCTORS BUT I
CAN'T SAY THE FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS I KNOW THAT WE
ALWAYS LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
MOST OF THOSE AREAS USE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT RECRUIT DOCTORS. TO BE
THERE AND BECAUSE OF THAT-
THERE IS A GREAT NEED FOR
NURSES TO BE TOOK TO BECAUSE
THE NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
pTHEN THEY BECOME REGISTERED
NURSES SO THAT IS THE SHORTEST
IS THERE THOSE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THE WORK IN THOSE
AREAS A LOT OF. ONCE THEY GET
TO A POINT WHERE RETURN GONE.
EFFORTS TO GET TO MOVE INTO
THOSE AREAS IS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT AND FINALLY A
TERRORIST SO OBVIOUSLY WERE.
CURRENT THAT PANDEMIC AT THE
GOVERNOR HAS MAKE CALLS FOR
HEALTHCARE PROFESSION THE
COMMON. AND BE AVAILALE TO
ASSIST AND- CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHETHER AT AND I UNDERSTAND TO
THE IMPULSES THAT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED. THE NURSES THAT YOU A
PROCESS UNDER HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER EMERGENCY POWERS TO
ALLOWED TO PRACTICE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT CORRECT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED SO FAR. I'M NOT
SURE THAT NUMBER'S CORRECT-
THAT IS THROUGH HIM SO THE
FEMUR I THINK IT'S EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES TORTILLA MAY
HAVE THE AFTERNOON INCORRECT
BUT THAT DOES NOT COME DIRECTLY
THROUGH US WE'RE AWARE WHAT IS
GOING ON- BUT THAT DOES NOT
COME THROUGH US. THAT ARE YOU
AWARE OF ANY CURRENT SHORTAGES
IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. TERMS OF NURSES
AVAILABILITY OF NURSES NO WE
ARE NOT AS A MATTER OF FACT
THERE ARE SOME CASES THAT HAVE
TO LOOK OFF NURSE. AS THEY-
NEED IT. WE'RE NOT. CAN YOU TO
CURE UNITS ARE WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO COME IN WITH COLBY IT
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE A FIRST DOWN A
RED AND WE THE HAS NOT.
ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN A
ABOUT AS FAR A SURE A
REGISTERED NURSES BEING
AVAILABLE SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE DIGITAL TESTIMONY
SENATOR DODD. YEAH YOU KNOW I
THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT-
IS GOT MY ATTENTION I HAD SOME.
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT A STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
BUT YOU'LL HAVE TRAVIS AIR
FORCE BASE IN BY. YOUR IN MY
DISTRICT AND I GET A NUMBER OF
CALLS- THROUGHOUT THE YEAR FROM
THE YEAH THAT. THEY THE HEAD OF
THE- THE BASE IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD SAY HEY WE'RE YOUR WORK
OR BRING IT ALL THIS TOP
MILITARY FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD. THEIR WIVES ARE. FOR
EXAMPLE OR HUSBANDS WOULD
REGARD AS WELL YEAH. WITH
REGARD TO YEAH WITH WHOEVER'S
IN IN THE SERVICE. SAY HEY THEY
DON'T PASS. YEAH THEY DON'T
PASS BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA
TEST IT OUT WELL I HEAR YOU AND
I HEAR PEOPLE SAY WERE THE BEST
IN THE WORLD DEAL WE ALWAYS
THINK WE'RE THE BEST THE WORLD
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S JUST. KIND
OF WHO WE ARE I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S REAL I'M NOT SURE THAT
IN A TOTAL. AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED SOME. AB THIRD PARTY
VERIFICATION OF THESE STANDARDS
AND WHY THEY'RE SO MUCH BETTER
THAN. OTHER STATES WHERE PEOPLE
ARE ALLOWED TO PRACTICE. IT SO
I'D- MY PROBLEM OF THE GIVE YOU
A COURTESY VOTE TODAY- ON THIS
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE THE
DIALOG CONTINUE AND I WANT TO
TALK TO- A CNA AND OTHERS WHO
OPPOSE THIS BUT I LOOK AT THE
LONG LIST OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND IT
STARTS MAKE ME WONDER. YEAH
WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE WE
PROTECTING THE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OR ARE WE ADVANCING
POLICY TO- CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO GET
THE HEALTH CARE THAT'S NEEDED
BUT I DO RESERVE THE RIGHT- YOU
KNOW IN THE VOTE. YEAH ON THE
SENATE FLOOR TO CHANGE MY MIND
ON THIS BASED ON FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CENTER
LEYVA. I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT. I THINK THIS IS THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES HERE- GOOD BAD
INDIFFERENT. WHEN THIS BE
BETTER TAKEN UP UNDER SUNSET
REVIEW SO WE COULD HAVE A FULL
DEBATE. I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
SUNSET REVIEW IS. THIS THAT
WOULD BE THE BETTER TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS CENTER
LEYVA ALL THE NOTES AND I'LL
ASK MY STAFF TO CORRECTLY THAT
WE THE SUNSET REVIEW FOR THAT
BOARD IS UP AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE NEXT YEAR. BY HERE TO
COLLEGE AND FROM MY STAFF'S SO
THAT'S A DIRECT ANSWER YOUR-
COURSE. ALL RIGHT IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS A
LITTLE IT CENTER MORE LOCK. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE IN THAT I
HAVE SOME- SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS AS WELL CENTER MORE
LIFE. THIS FEATURE- THANKS FOR
THE DISCUSSION- AS I STATED
EARLIER WITH THE CONSULTANTS.
AT PLANETARY SIDE I THINK THERE
ARE A FEW AREAS WHERE THEY'RE
NOT ACCURATE OR- THERE. IS SO
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS ARE ASKED THAT YOU'RE
ALLOWED. REBEKAH FIGHTS TO
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS-
I WILL SAY THAT. THIS TO POINT
OUT A COUPLE- ONE OR JUST ONE
THE BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR THE
COMPACT ARE DONE BY THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION THE FBI
SO. I WE WERE WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HERE.
PRETTY HEIST FOR. A WHO IS
APPROVED TO BE A NURSE- IN
THIRTY FOUR STATES AND
CALIFORNIA. THIS TO THE
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING ENOUGH
NURSES. THERE WAS TWO FOLD ONE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE PRODUCING
ENOUGH WAS THE STATEMENT BY MS
HARRIS SO IF THAT'S ACCURATE
THEN WE HAVE NURSES THAT COULD
HELP THE OTHER THIRTY FOUR
STATES GIVES THEM. AN UP TO BE
EMPLOYED. IT ALSO GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL HEALTH
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES THE AUTHORITY TO HELP
THOSE I UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WERE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE HAVING ISSUES WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH HOSPITALS DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH CLINICS. SO THE
OTHER POINT WAS THAT. MANY
NURSES HAVE BEEN LAID OFF
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WE PUT AFTER HOSPITALS
IN OUR MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS
JUST TO FOCUS ON ONE THING
WE'VE WE'VE MADE. SO MANY
HOSPITALS IN FACT JUST FOCUSED
ON PAVILION NOTHING ELSE
NOTHING OPTIONAL NO OPTIONAL
SURGERIES NOTHING ELSE IS SOLD
WE WE'VE WE'VE KIND OF BEEN
DECIMATING A- A PROFESSION THAT
WE NEED TO PUT THAT BACK
TOGETHER BUT THAT'S A
DISCUSSION FOR ANOTHER TIME.
MISTER CHAIR THE NURSE
LICENSURE COMPACT HAS BEEN
FUNCTIONING FOR TWENTY YEARS.
NEW JERSEY ADJUST TO PROVE
THEIR LEGISLATION LAST YEAR AND
PROBABLY IN THE NICK OF TIME
BECAUSE IT HELPS. BRING A LOT
OF NURSES TO NEW JERSEY TO A
DEAL WITH THE COKE AT NINETEEN.
A PANDEMIC. THE MAJORITY OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED THE CONSULTANTS
THOROUGH ANALYSIS CAN BE
RESOLVED I BELIEVE THROUGH THE
AWARENESS. THAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS OPTIONAL OR WITH
MINOR CORRECTIVE.
ADMINISTRATIVE REGULATIONS OR
LEGISLATION IN THE NEXT SESSION
THESE ARE NOT DIFFICULT ISSUES.
SB TEN FIFTY THREE HAS AN
IMPRESSIVE LIST OF SUPPORTERS.
FROM THE US SECRETARY OF THE
ARMY. THE SOME TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL REGISTERED
NURSES AND JUST RECENTLY NOT ON
YOUR LIST THE RED CROSS. IT'S
NOT A MATTER OF IF CALIFORNIA
MOVES IN THIS DIRECTION IT'S A
MATTER OF WHEN. WITH COVERT
NINETEEN. THERE COULDN'T BE A
STRONGER MOTIVATOR CONSEQUENTLY
I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB
TEN FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LOCK- I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO YOU FIRST FOR STIMULATING A
VERY IMPORTANT AND-
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION TODAY.
ABOUT THIS A ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
I AND I KNOW THAT THE
MOTIVATION THAT YOU HAVE IS A
IT IS A AND AN ADMIRABLE ONE.
TWO WILL IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY ACCESSIBILITY OF
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM OF THOSE
WHO PRACTICE. OF BOTH FOR
CONSUMERS AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN IT. AND I THINK IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
TO HAVE AYE AYE NOTE SENATOR
DODD SET. REMARKS ABOUT TRYING
TO- DIG DOWN DEEPER ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST. CREATING AN
ARTIFICIAL BARRIER BUT ONE THAT
IS CONSTRUCTIVE THE THAT MEETS
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS BUT ALSO
IS IT KEEPS IN MIND- THE DESIRE
TO. HELP THOSE WHO PRACTICE IN
THAT FIELD IN THOSE WHO CONSUME
IT- TO MAKE OUR WORLD A BETTER
PLACE. CERTAINLY THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE REYES
AND OTHERS HAVE RAISED OVER
MANY YEARS ABOUT HOW MUCH TIME
IT TAKES. FOR A NURSE WHO HAS
PRACTICED IN ANOTHER STATE TO
COME HERE AND PRACTICE- IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE A BEARS
REVIEW AND- I WILL NOTE THAT WE
HAVE A REVIEW IN MIND- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IS UP FOR
SUNSET REVIEW. FOR THOSE WHO
AREN'T FAMILIAR IT MEANS THAT
IF. IF THAT REVIEW WAS NOT
COMPLETED- ON TIME- THAT BOARD
TO GO OUT OF EXISTENCE SO
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE. TO
AFTER THIRTY MINUTES OF THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING- THE
TIME IT TAKES THEM TO REVIEW
APPLICANTS. WHO WANT TO
PRACTICE WHETHER THAT'S
REASONABLE OR NOT TO EXAMINE
THE ISSUES OF FRAUD- THAT THAT-
THE DAY ARE CHARGE WITH THE AND
FORCE IT IS A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT GO INTO THAT REVIEW. AND I
THINK THAT THIS DEBATE HERE
TODAY IS THE KIND OF
CONVERSATION WE SHOULD HAVE IT
REVIEW. TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT-
WE ARE CREATING ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS- THAT LIMIT THE ACCESS
TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE THAT WE
ALL WANT. OUR STATE AND SO FOR
ME. WITH YOUR LEGISLATION. I
WOULD BE. PUTTING IN A DEPOSIT
BUTTON ON IT THE TODAY AND
GIVEN US THE CHANCE TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION OF THE
DIALOGUE AND ENGAGEMENT THAT WE
WILL DO THROUGH OUR SUNSET
REVIEW NEXT YEAR. AND SO ON FOR
ME TODAY IT SAID NOT YET-
AVAILABLE. AND NOT A NO VOTE
BUT NOT YET A LITTLE BIT AND- I
WANT TO GET EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION FOR. YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
CONVERSATION- AND I'M SURE IT
WILL CONTINUE INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY MOTION TO BE MADE. SENATOR
CHECK. THE MOVE BY THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED AND WHAT'S THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE REMEMBER TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE SO THAT IT CAN BE
RECORDED CORRECTLY. SB TEN AT
FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER
NOW. PLEASE OR NO CHANGE HIGH.
PAYING AYE ARCHULETA NO.
ARCHULETA NO DODD. DODD I
GALGIANI HI GALGIANI I HELL TO
BILL NO LEYVA- LEAVE I KNOW PAN
THOUGH AND NO WILK HI WILK I.
THE ARE THE COUNTER THE MEASURE
HAS FOR A VOTES AND FIVE NEW
BEDS OKAY. CENTER UNFORTUNATELY
TODAY AT LEAST THAT MEASURE
WILL BE HELD HERE IN COMMITTEE-
FOUR TO FIVE- WE GENERALLY AS A
COURTESY ALWAYS PROVIDE A
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
HEARING A SCHEDULED- FOR US IN
TERMS OF MEETING OUR OUR HOUSE
ABORTION DEADLINES BUT- IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION- I WILL. I
TAKE THAT AS A MOTION TO
CONSPIRE RECONSIDER CENTER IF
YOU'D LIKE. TO HAVE A RECOUNT
MR JR A RECAP ACTED. WE DIDN'T
HAVE PAPER BALLOTS- OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO- WILL WILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL THAT MATTER WILL
BE- RECONSIDERED- AND- AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT THE
NEXT BILL OUR REGION. AND IS TO
BE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TEN
FIFTY FOUR CENTER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES SB TEN FIFTY FOUR
FOLLOWS THE SAME LOGIC AS- TEN
FIFTY THREE. IT WOULD ENTER
CALIFORNIA INTO THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST COMPACT THIS WILL
PROVIDE LICENSING RECIPROCITY
FOR PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPIST ASSISTANTS
AND A CONTACT NETWORK THAT
CURRENTLY INCLUDES TWENTY SIX
OTHER STATES. MISTER CHAIR OF
BASED ON OUR LAST DISCUSSION ON
SB TEN FIFTY THREE I WILL
ABBREVIATE MY REMARKS- FOR SB
TEN FIFTY FOUR AS THEY ARE VERY
SIMILAR. UP MAY I PLEASE
REQUEST THAT MY TWO WITNESSES
HAVE A CHANCE TO. TESTIFY AND
MAKE THEIR PRESENTATIONS IT IS
MY HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER A LICENSING
COMPACT IN THIS INSTANCE. IN
ORDER TO HAVE SACRAMENTO PUT
ITS TOES IN THE WATER. SO TO
SPEAK AND OBTAIN EXPERIENCE
FROM INVOLVEMENT IN MISS
NETWORK HOPEFULLY. IT WILL
PROVIDE A COMFORT LEVEL FOR
PURSUING SIMILAR RELATIONSHIPS
IN THE FUTURE. MR SURE I'D LIKE
TO ASK TJ CAN'T WELL THE
COMPACT ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY CONTACT TO
TESTIFY AND ALSO MISTER CARL
LUNDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. VERY GOOD CENTER
MORE LOCK OPERATOR I'D LIKE TO
ASK IF MR CAN'T WELL AND MISTER
LONDON ARE AVAILABLE ON THE
LINE IF YOU COULD OPEN UP THEIR
LINE SO THEY COULD PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. THE GENTLEMAN YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN. HI MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT MEMBERS THIS IS
CARL LONDON AGAIN- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY FOUR.
WE BELIEVE THIS MEASURE
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO MODERN
SOCIETY FOR MOBILITY THERE'S A
PROBLEM SOLVE ORDER- FOR
HELPING US MEET OUR CURRENT
HEALTHCARE NEEDS WE BELIEVE
THIS OFFERS IMPROVED ACCESS TO
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSISTANT.
REACH CHOICE PORTABILITY AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES. AND COMBINED WITH
TELEHEALTH WE BELIEVE THIS CAN
BE ESPECIALLY POWERFUL TOOL.
FOR MEETING THE DEMANDS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS I WOULD NOTE
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
NOW CHANGE THAT MEDICARE LAW TO
ALLOW HELLO HOW ARE YOU FIRST
FOR TELEHEALTH. ACROSS STATE
LINES SO THIS MAY IN FACT BE A
GREAT MODEL TO LOOK AT IS
CENTER BOX ITSELF- TEN FIFTY
FOUR PRESERVES. OUR STATE
LICENSING SYSTEM IN ACTUALLY
ENHANCES PUBLIC PROTECTION.
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN STATES BY
INSURING. DISPLACEMENT LICENSE
AND DISCIPLINARY DATA SHARING
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS. IN
THE WHITE CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
DEMONSTRATION OF CONTINUING
COMPETENCE IN ONE EAR ONE
THEORY OF EXPERTISE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT ALL PUSH THIS OVER
TO THE SCANT WELL WHO WORKS
WITH THE PHYSICAL THERAPY.
COMPACT COMMISSION CURRENTLY.
THANK YOU MISTER LONDON MISTER
CAN'T WELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS PETER
CAN'T WHILE I AM THE CONTACT
AND THE SHORTER POLITICAL
THERAPY COMPACT COMMISSION
WHICH IS- IN CHARGE OF THE
TIANANMEN OPERATIONS I'M
ALTHOUGH WE ARE SIMILAR TO THE
NURSING CONTACT WE DO OPERATE
DIFFERENTLY. THE COMMISSION IS
INDEPENDENT GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY
THAT CURRENTLY CONSISTS OF
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT STATES THAT
HAVE SEEN THE BENEFITS OF
JOINING TWENTY TO BE TO CONTACT
AND THEREFORE NOT TO THE SAME
LEGISLATION YOU ARE CONSIDERING
TODAY. THE PURPOSE OF THE P. TO
CONVERT THIS FACILITY
INTERSTATE PRACTICE OF MEDICAL
THERAPY WITH THE GOAL OF
IMPROVING PUBLIC ACCESS-
DILUTED WITH THERE BE SERVICES
WHILE STILL ENHANCING PUBLIC
PROTECTIONS- THE BT COMBAT IS
AN ALTERNATE PATHWAY. OF BILLS
GO THERE FOR THEM TO GO THERE
BE PROVIDERS MEET ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS TO OBTAIN APPROVAL
TO PRACTICE OTHER STATES AND
THEY CAN DO SO WITHIN A MATTER
OF MINUTES INSTEAD OF DAYS
WEEKS AND MONTHS. ARE THERE
SEVERAL BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIANS PROVIDERS. IN ITS
RESIDENTS INCLUDING- IMPROVE
ACCESS TO ACCESS TO IN CHOICE
OF DIFFICULT THERE TO PROVIDERS
FOR EVERYONE INCLUDING THOSE IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. I THEY
PULLED. THE PLACE. TO IT.
PUBLIC BY REQUIRING PRODUCE.
PARTICIPATE INNOCENT.
HIGHLIGHTS INTO. DAY SYSTEM.
IDYLLWILD THE FIVE TO THE RUN
INVESTIGATION. SET THE STANDARD
AMONG ALL ARE THE FBI KERN
BACKGROUND FOR ANYONE SEEKING
INITIAL LICENSURE. ARMY DOES
NOT PROVIDE FOR DELIVERY OF
ALTERNATIVE METHODS OF CARE
SUCH TELEHEALTH I WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL IMPORTANT TIMES LIKE
THESE PROMENADE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTS MILITARY FAMILIES BY
GREATLY IMPROVING THE
PORTABILITY FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES. THE COMPACT IS ALL
THIS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF SLICK CALIFORNIA
TO DETERMINE OVERSEE ENFORCE
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE UNDER
WHICH PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPIST ASSISTANTS
CAN PRACTICE. THE STATE IS NOT
RELIANT ON A HOME STATE LICENSE
IN ORDER TO TAKE AT LEAST ORGAN
ORDER TO TAKE ACTION THE STATE
ITSELF CAN TAKE ACTION AGAINST
ANYBODY HOLD A COMPACT
PRIVILEGE. IN CALIFORNIA I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER I CAN'T WELL WE'RE
GONNA INVITE OTHERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT TO-
PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY- HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. IN THE
CAPITOL AND ON THE PHONE I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT IF YOU
DO WISH TO SUPPORT THAT THIS
LEGISLATION YOU PROVIDE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND THAT.
YOUR INDICATION OF SUPPORT SO I
LIKE TO INVITE ANYONE HERE AND
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE TO
SPEAK. PLEASE BUT THE
MICROPHONE. BRENT WITH THE TO
HEALTH AND A DIVISION VOTING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. FOR THE HANDS ARE
GONNA GO. TWENTY FOUR ANYONE IN
ROO TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO
HANDS THERE ARE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR WOULD
YOU ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR
WARLOCK PLEASE SO INDICATE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO TESTIFY ONE ZERO THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL ALIGN FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARIA NUMBER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN COURT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT. WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MARIA REFINE
YOUR HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
ARE WE ARE EXPLAINS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY
SIX. YOUR TURN MEMBERS AMY AMY
BLOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FIFTY TWO
POLICE. I KNOW YOU MAY THAT LET
OUT A VERY. KELLY MAY THAT BUT
WITHOUT DEPARTMENT. IN THE
COURT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE WILL GO TO FIFTEEN LINE
FIFTEEN YEAR OPEN. MOVING ALONG
WILL ALIGN SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHAD
OPTION ALL SPEAKING AS CO CHAIR
OF CALIFORNIA DEPEND COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WILL PRETENDING DEFEND
COMMUNITY TO CALL CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS CHAIR OF THE STEEL
MILITARY LIAISON COUNSEL
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR NEXT WITH
THIS PLEASE. WE ARE DEADLINE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOS.
TWENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. BY
NINETY SIX WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THEN HEALTHCARE PART OF THE
ESPY TEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE OPERATOR. BUILT IN LINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS SANDY. THE VERY MUCH
THAT'S WITH THIS PLEASE
OPERATOR. FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE WILL BOTH WILL TRY LINE
FIFTEEN AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS RICHARD GAS AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
THERAPY ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATORS ANYBODY ELSE IN Q. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. BUT AT THIS TIME.
GOOD WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUT
THOSE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
FIRST WILL BEGIN HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THREE BODY HERE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION.
SAYS SB TEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MORLOCK C. NO HANDS
REYES REGULAR ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ONE A TWENTY FORTY WHICH TO
TESTIFY. I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS
RAISE THEIR SERVER GOING OVER
THE PHONE LINES. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINES WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
FIFTY FOUR. SOME OF THE PHONE
LINES TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO THIS TIME.
WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH LEAD HERE
THAT AIM P. PASSING THAT.
PUTTING THE BILL. RIGHT VERY
GOOD OPERATOR CANNOT THE BODY
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. SHE
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TEST AT THE TIME
TO PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY ELSE
IS KILLING TO COME VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OP SO WE'RE
GOING BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CALL ARE.
MA'AM. CENTER GARCIA. I'D LIKE
TO. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING THE BILL FOR
IT I TO WORK AS A PHYSICAL
THERAPY AIDE AT ST LOOKING
GENERAL HOW. MANY YEARS AGO. AT
ONE POINT IN TIME WE HAD TO
THERAPY. WHO OF LEFT DIFFERENT
TIME AND FOR A WHILE WE HAD NO.
THERAPY THAT WAS A TO COVER.
OUR PATIENT ROUNDS ON THE
WEEKENDS AND WE RELIED HEAVILY
ON THE PHYSICAL THERAPY
REGISTRY. SO I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS TO CREATE CREATE
GREATER FLEXIBILITY ENSURE THAT
SOME OF THE- HOSPITALS AND
FACILITIES AT A HAVE A MORE
DIFFICULT TIME RECRUITING
THERAPISTS. HAVE THE ABILITY TO
STILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CARE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND ALL MOVE
THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GALGIANI. CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU I. MEAN I STILL HAVE.
CAN SIMILAR CAN. WITH THIS BILL
AS WELL. DO YOU KNOW WHEN THE-
NEXT REVIEW OF THIS BOARD WILL
COME UP. FOR THIS. WHAT'S THE
ASK OUR PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT
SURVEYS THIRTEEN. THE BOARD IS
THIS TO EXPIRE ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ABOUT THE REVIEW IS
SCHEDULED TO TAKE PLACE NEXT
YEAR OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I HAVE
JUST ONE CENTER MORE LACKEY
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE- TO US FOR THIS
CONVERSATION. THE INFORMATION
THAT I HAVE IS THAT THE IF YOU
WANTED TO COME IN THE
CALIFORNIA. TO PRACTICE AS A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST- THAT THE
PROCESS THAT THE BOARD HAS
ESTABLISHES THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY BEGIN WORK IMMEDIATELY
EARN A PAYCHECK- HEALTH
PRACTICE YOUR TRADE- UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A STATE LICENSE-
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST. OR GAIN A
LICENSE ROUGHLY A FEW WEEKS
AFTER FLIGHT SO THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE- EXPERIENCE WITH THE NURSES-
TERMS OF AN AVERAGE EIGHT WEEK-
LAG. DID YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION AT SPEAKS
DIFFERENTLY TO THE AND THE FACT
THAT I PRESENTED TO YOU. NO I
DO NOT MISTER CHAIR I DO.
BELIEVE THAT TEST WHAT A
DAMAGES WE HAVE YOUR
TELEHEALTH. AND THEN ALSO THE
MOBILITY TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
OTHER STATES QUICKLY. BUT MR
CAN'T WEALTHIEST ON THE LINE
MIGHT MIGHT HAVE A GOOD
RESPONSE. MR DECK CAN WELL IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE DO YOU
HAVE A ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW LONG IT TAKES A OUT OF
STATE PHYSICAL THERAPISTS TO A
PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN UP
THE LONG LINES FOR MR CAN'T
WELL PLEASE. IT'S OPEN. HI OUT
YES- I SLOWLY SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
HOW LONG IT TAKES FOR A P. T.
TO GET A LIFE OF AS BY THE
STATE BOARD I CAN NO TO THAT
THE COMPACT PRIVILEGE- CAN BE
ISSUED- WITHIN LESS THAN TEN
MINUTES ONCE THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
COMPLETED THEIR JURISPRUDENCE
EXAM WHICH ALLOW MY I'M
POSITIVE IS NOT- IT IS MUCH
ASTER THAN ANY STATE BOARD AND
COMPLETE LICENSURE REVIEW AN
ISSUE OF THE PRIVILEGE
PRACTICING OTHER STATES SO THE
SYSTEM WAS SET UP TO VERIFY.
ALL ELIGIBLE IS PROVIDE AN OP
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ESSENTIALLY A
GREATER THE ACROPOLIS PRACTICE
WITH WITHIN THE SAY DAY AFTER
THEY CAN THE STATE TERROR EXAM
UNTIL WILL BE PROVIDED TO BE
MUCH FASTER NOW TO GET A
COMPLETE THE TO PRACTICE THE
NOT REQUIRE SUPERVISION THANK
YOU MISTER WELL YOU SEE AND MY
MASS MY SMALL. AS I SEE THAT
VERY SIX BRIDGE BACK TO WHY THE
SLEDGES IS OF THE UPDATE THAT I
ASKED TO REMAINS AT LEAST AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
SEE WE GET SEE WE HAVE A
PROBLEM TODAY FIVE SO WHAT
SIXTY OF IT WILL WE CAN DO TO
FIX IT AND THEN OF COURSE THE
TERM OF A BROADER CON GRIEVING
I. SAID MORE LACKEY AGAIN WITH
MY **** TO A QUIET THIS IS A
WORTHY TO HAVE AND WHY I THINK
TO OUR SUNSET REVIEW. A BIG
NEXT YEAR I THINK IT'S A THAT I
HOPE THAT WE WILL BE. TO DO
DEEPER IT IF YOU LEGISLATION
THAT IT MOVED. OKAY WITH THAT I
MATTER. THE MOTION IS TO
CHAIRMAN. YES IT CHAIRMAN MADE
MAN A CRACK AT ANSWERING THIS
CARL LUNDEN ON BEHALF OF THE-
COULD TOO SO IT'S- THIS BILL
AND ONLY THE GO OF THE FAT. SO
THAT I HAVE SERVED INTO THE
THEIR TRUE OR THE FALLS THE
OTHER WAY WE'RE GOING TO THIS
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND CALL THAT HEARING THIS ITEM.
YES SPECIFIC. EIGHT WELL I.
HAVE ANY. INTRODUCED AS YOU.
HEARD EARLIER. IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TO SEND BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT. BUT JONES. WE
SOME. SEE IS. RESPONSE AND- OF
HOW QUICKLY. GET LIFE. WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE SUPPORT OF THAT BILL.
TO WE SEE THIS BILL COMPLEMENT.
THAT A FAQ. AND I WOULD ALSO
NOTE. THAT WILL. IS OF. THE
THIRD MOST. SOUGHT AFTER PER.
RIGHT NOW AMONG HEALTHCARE FOR.
IN TERMS OF NEW. AND BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF FISCAL. WE
PRODUCE. INCOME WE WILL FALL
SHE- IT COULD. TO FOR. OUR
PROJECT. THAT TO. TWO SIX WEEKS.
THE. IS HE A CRITICAL PASS
TOWARDS SOLVING THAT PROBLEM
FOR CAL. THANK YOU GOOD THANK
MISTER LE SO I GONNA NOW. THE
MOTION CENTER ON THIS IS A PASS
A- I TO APPROPRIATIONS ZACHARY.
THIS MASON. OKAY AND WITH THAT
LIKE THE CHECK TO CALL THE ROLL.
OF A SOUTH PART ME YES AND
WARLOCK BY PAULA TO YOU. THANK
YOU THE MORNING. OF MISTER
CHAIR I GUESS SO START UP AS A
THAT THE- THERAPY. INDUSTRY
ACTUALLY SUPPORTIVE OF. BILL
AND TO A WE DIDN'T HEAR
OPPOSITION SO THAT'S KIND OF
NICE WE DID GET. A EVEN SO FROM
THE- OF. SO THAT CERTAINLY MAIL
SPOUSE OR ARE TAKING THE- SO
JUST REALLY. WITH SPORTS BILL
IS GENERATED- THERE IS- THERE
WILL BE OCCASIONS WHEN THE CASE
OF AN UNFORESEEN CALAMITY. A
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED ASSISTANCE
ON AN IMMEDIATE BASIS FROM
PRACTITIONERS AND OTHER STATES.
AND OTHER STATES MAY NEED ARE
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS AS WELL.
WE'RE LEARNING RIGHT NOW THAT
IT IS BETTER TO BE EARLY. AND
THEN TO BE FLAT FOOTED WHEN
SOMETHING DOES ARISE. SB TEN
FIFTY FOUR MOVES CALIFORNIA
INTO THE FUTURE IT DISPLAYS A
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT. AND IT
WILL SHOW FOR SITE AND
CONSEQUENTLY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON. SENATE
BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MORE LOCK AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE SB TEN FIFTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED
THROUGH PERFORATIONS. GLAZER
NOW. LASER NOTE. HI BANG AYE
ARCHULETA NO. ARCHULETA NOTE.
HI DOT I YELLED. I FELT AYE.
NEW BILL. LEYVA NO LEYVA NOPE
HAN THOUGH. AND NO WILL HI.
WELL I. MEASURE HAS FOUR AYE
VOTES AND FIVE NOTED A CENTER
MORE LOCKED THAT BILL IS DOES
NOT GOING FORWARD THE FOR YES
FIVE NOW AB WITHOUT OBJECTION
ALL ASKED THAT WE- CONSIDER THE
MATTER RECONSIDERED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER MORE LOCKED.
LIKE TO INVITE UP BY SENATOR
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE. THERE
MCGUIRE WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. EIGHT AT THE
OPPORTUNITY BETTER PRESENTED
HOPE ALL HAD A GOOD WEEKEND-
YES IT IS A PLEASURE TO BE ABLE
TO I INTRODUCED TO SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE TO THE COMMITTEE.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS SAID
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES IN THE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES IN AFTER
LOSING EVERYTHING SURVIVORS
BEGIN THE CHALLENGING TASK OF
REBUILDING THEIR HOMES AND OF
COURSE THEIR LIVES THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN SOME THE
LARGEST DISASTER REBUILDING
EFFORTS IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY. LOSING A HOME DRAMATIC
ENOUGH BUT ANY NOT PUTTING ON
EXPERIENCE CONTRACTOR OR WORSE
A CONTRACTOR WHO IN IN A WHO
INTENTIONALLY TAKES A JOB
KNOWING THAT THEY CAN'T FINISH
IT HAS MADE THE REBUILDING
PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
THE HEALING PROCESS INCREDIBLY
DRAMATIC. CURRENTLY THERE IS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH FOR
ALL CONTRACTORS DAVY A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE THIS
ALLOWS CONTRACTORS TO TAKE ON
JOBS FROM BOTTLING. TO I SCRIPT
LITTLE ITALY LATE SINCE THIS IS
A LICENSE TRACK WHO NORMALLY DO
SOME READ PROJECTS WE KITCHEN
IN BATHROOMS FOR EXAMPLE TO
MEET THE TAKE ON LARGER JOB
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE OF DOING LIKE READ
POEM DESPITE OR DOING A FULL WE
BEFORE WE SAW THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. SECOND ABLE TO BE.
TO A SENATOR DOT ON THIS IS WE
WORK VERY CLOSE ON IN. WE SAW
THIS AND OVER IN PART IN CENTER.
CON WITH NO PREVIOUS. OF THE
INTO HOME TAKE ON A READ
PROJECT COPY PARK IS A WORKING
CLASS NEIGHBORHOOD FOR ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO HOMES WERE WIPED OFF
THE FACE OF THE EARTH BY THE
TUBS FIRE. AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THE MAJORITY OF
CONTRACTORS WHO BEEN IN THE
REBUILD FROM THE TUBS FIRE IN
ALL OF THE OTHER NORTE FIRES
HAVE DONE THE RIGHT THING. BUT
THERE ARE FEW CONTRACTORS
REPRESENTING SEVERAL DOZEN
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS THAT
CHARGE FIRE VICTIMS AND FULL
PRICE TO REBUILD ST INCLUDED
SHODDY WORK. AND COUNTLESS
MISTAKES SOME JOBS THEY WERE
EVEN COMPLETED SOME JOBS
WEREN'T STARTED THESE
CONTRACTORS SHOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN IN THE BUSINESS A REBUILDS
THEY LACK. A SERIES IN. FOR THE
JOB. SURVIVOR TWO WENT TO THE
DRAMATIC A- OF LIVING FOR A
WHILE. THEY HAD A DEAL WITH
THEIR DAY KANT. WHO WERE
IMPROPERLY FREE WALL.
INSTALLING FRAME. IN PUTTING
WINDOWS IN. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE LOOKS THE STATE ONE FITS
ALL CONTRACTORS LICENSING
SCHEME. RATHER THAN ALL
CONTRACTORS HAVING A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE TO
LICENSES WOULD BE USHERED IN.
ONE THAT WOULD BE FOCUS ON
REMODELS THIS WOULD BE NEW. AND
THE OTHER FOCUS ON HOME
CONSTRUCTION THIS IS THE
CURRENT SITUATION. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE TRANSPARENCY THAT
CONSUMERS JUST REALLY NEED
ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF
DISASTER. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
EXTEND HOME IMPROVEMENT LAW
PROTECTIONS THE FULL HOME
RECONSTRUCTION AFTER DISASTERS.
THERE'S A LOOPHOLE CURRENTLY
THE LAW PROVIDES CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ON HOME REMODELS
AND REPAIRS PROTECTIONS. AS
WELL SUCH AS REQUIRING WORK TO
BE COMPLETED BEFORE FULL
PAYMENT CAN BE DEMANDED.
HOWEVER THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHILE THEY DO NOT
INCLUDE HOME RECONSTRUCTION.
REBUILDS RESTORATION FOR
STRUCTURES LOST TO NATURAL
DISASTER. THE BILL WOULD EXPAND
TO THESE COMMONSENSE
PROTECTIONS ADDITIONALLY ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL CLOSE ANOTHER
LOOPHOLE IN OUR CRIMINAL LAWS
WHICH CURRENTLY DO NOT INCLUDE
HOME REBUILDS. IN THE
DEFINITION OF HOME IMPROVEMENT
I KNOW IT SOUNDS CRAZY BUT IT'S
SIMPLY A LOOPHOLE. CURRENTLY
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE HESITANT
TO PROSECUTE UNLICENSED
CONTRACTORS FOR TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF FIRE SURVIVORS
BECAUSE THE LAWS ARE CLEAR IF
THOSE CRIMINAL PROVISIONS. ALSO
APPLIED TO REBUILD IN
RESTORATIONS. I THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AGAIN I'M TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
SIR IN YOUR CREDIT STAFF THIS
LED TO. IS SUPPORTED BY THE CON
STATE. BOARD I WANT TO TAKE A
SAFE YOU. FOR THE TO THE BOY
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION SPECIALTY
CONTRACTORS. AND THE LARGE
ASSOCIATE GENERAL CONTRACTORS
GROUP- IN THE CITY SANTA ROSA
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS FINALLY
MR CHAIR AS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS IN THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD. TO CLARIFY ELECTRICAL
WORK IN THE NEW LICENSE
CLASSIFICATION I'M SURE YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR FOR FROM THEM THIS
MORNING SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WERE
CAN REALLY GOING TO WORK OUT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IF YOU WOULD
ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD HERE
TODAY. I PLEASED TO HAVE WITH
US TODAY I'D AND MICHAEL I'D TO
MET SKIING HE'S CHIEF OF
LEGISLATIVE BUDGETARY
REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE DAVID DOING HOOTIE
ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA WITH US ON
THE LINE IS WELL MICHAELS I CAN
BE HERE IN PERSON. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE GOING
ON SO LONG. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE NO NO PAULNEEDED IS
SUCH A VALUABLE. BILL OBVIOUSLY
A IN THIS EXPERIENCE. FIRST I.
WOULD WITHIN YOUR SO INVITE YOU
WITNESSES COME ON A BY YOUR ONE
HERE IN THE. MISTER JANETTE SKI.
AND THEN ONE OF MISTER HI IS IT
WHEN TO TRY TO ON THE PHONE
LINE WELCOME SIR. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR COMMITTEE MY DRAMATIC
WITH THE STATE LICENSE BOARD OR
CS BE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THIS FOR ON IMPORT ISSUE THIS
BILL OF MANY IMPORTANT. BUT IN
THE INTEREST TIME OFF ON TO
THOSE ARE REMOVING TO LICENSE.
AND SETTING AMINIMUM IN THE
PRESENT REMODEL INDUSTRY. THIS
COMMITTEE RECALL YOU MARCHED
NINETEEN THE BOARD WITH ASKED
DURING A SUNSET TO. IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL TO. IN ITS PROGRAMS
AND ONE OF THEM WAS
CONSERVATIVELY FIFTY TO SEVENTY
A MONTH WE GET FOR. CONTRACTORS
OR MOST OF TRADING REMODELLING
AND NOT ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
TERM CONTRA LIFE AT THE SAN
MEANT WITH THAT DOES IT THESE
RIGHT BACK INTO THE ON ECONOMY
AND THE BOARD NOTE THAT 25% ITS
CAN COME. WE WAIT TO HOME READ
AND REMODEL THAT ARE TWENTY
DOLLARS DOLLARS OR- SO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO LIFE IN THE MADE
BENEFIT THIS BILL THE TO
SENTIMENT STANDARD IN THE REST
REMOTE AND IF. AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED DO NOT. A CONTRACT
LICENSE RESIDENT REMODEL. BUT
THE BOARD IS A SEARCH
PROTECTION BY SETTING A STAY.
ENSURING THE WORK IS PERFORMED
COMPETENT WAIT TO BE BETTER THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE BOARD TO
CREATE AN EXAMINATION AND TESTS
THESE APPLICANTS FOR THIS
MINIMUM STANDARD RESIDENTIAL
REMODELLING AND THEN THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT PROVISIONS AND
AFTER AREAS WILL OUT AN ETRA
ELEMENT OF CONSUMER PROTECTION
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH SIR ALSO
TESTIFIED IN FAVOR FROM OUR
PHONE LINES DAVID QUINN FROM
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU ALLOW HIM TO
US. BE PLEASE. AT LEAST SEVEN
PLEASE WELL ONES. GOOD MORNING
SIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS MY NAME DAVID GIVE ON THIS
CITY MANAGER FOR THE OF SANTA
ROSA AND WE HAD A AN UP FRONT
THE TO THE ISSUE THAT THE BILL
IS LOOKING TO A WITH TO BUT THE
RESPONSE. IN TO THE SEVENTEEN
OUT IN THE TUBS FIRE WE LOST
OVER THREE THOUSAND HOMES WITH
THE CITY LIMITS. WE WORKING%
QUICK ALL AND ON DECK OF TO
WHAT ARE GOAL IN GETTING BACK
HOME AS QUICKLY POSSIBLE WE'RE
PROUD TO SAY THAT I JUST YEARS
IN WE HAVE OVER TWO EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMES REBUILD OR IN
PROCESS OF BEING. UNFORTUNATELY
WITH SPEED WITH THAT OF SPEED
IN THAT CHAOS AFTER LIKE THAT
BECAUSE MASSIVE TO. BECAUSE
ISSUES WE SAW THAT FIRST CON
GETTING OVER THE HEAD TAKEN ON
WHEN THEY. COULD TAKE A
UNDERSTANDING THE NEW ONE. OF
WHAT IT TO REAP. IT TO AND
POSTED AFTER. WITH. SUCH THAT
BILLS TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR
INDIVIDUALS INTO ANY SITUATION.
THAT'S A GOOD THING I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
MR GLENN TESTING AND CERTAINLY
FOR SHEPHERDING THAT SO MANY A
DIFFICULT- SITUATION THREE
YEARS YOUR CITY. SO THAT THE
EXHAUST THE WITNESSES IN FAVOR-
TERMS OF FULL TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA INVITE OTHERS WOULD LIKE
TO. DO A ME TOO WITH THEIR NAME
AN ORGANIZATIONAL PHILLY A TO
WHAT TO STEP FORWARD ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR. SEEING NO HANDS UP A GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
THERE. SEE NO HANDS UP THEIR
READING OF THE OPERATOR OF
PHONE LINES ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO. I TESTIFYING IN FAVOR OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE KEY SO INDICATE PLEASE.
LATER ON THE PHONE LINES PUSH
PRESS- ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
WAITING IN LINE TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF. THIS LEGISLATION ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THE OPERATORS
GATHERING THEY'RE NOT LINE
NUMBER. AND WE WILL LINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
SIXTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. YOU
CAN HEAR ME. YES SIR. OKAY
MORNING THE CHAIRMAN- MEMBER
THE COMMITTEE ANY BERNACCHI ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION- PEOPLE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE IN THIS YEAR'S WILL BE
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
NO SCOPE IMPACT ON OTHER
LICENSE CLASSIFICATIONS WE
REALLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
BRINGINGIN MORE SMALL
CONTRACTORS ON THE LICENSING
PROCESS AND WE'RE BURGER I VOTE
ON MOVING THIS POLICIES VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE IN Q.
TWO- IN LINE TO TESTIFY. I'LL
REMIND PEOPLE WERE ALL ASKING
FOR A NAME AND A ORGANIZATION
AFFILIATE AN INDICATION THAT
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE TEN
PLEASE CALL AT. HI THIS IS
JAMIE CALLING WITH THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE OPERATOR. YES WILL
ALIGN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD I AM GUNDER MY BURGER I'M
A GENERAL CONTRACTOR AND- DOES
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA I
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM BUT I
ALSO SIT ON THE GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS COMMITTEE FOR THE
AMERICAN SUB CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE. NOT AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WRITTEN BY
THE THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
LEGISLATION TO COME FORWARD
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO HANDS REYES I'VE-
BEEN TOLD THAT THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SERVER TO
GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES.
OPERATIVE QUEUE ASK IF ANYONE
IS A- CUTE UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
APPLE ISN'T OPPOSITION. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO A ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR. AND WE WILL LINE
ONE ZERO SIX ONE OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MEMBERS
RICHARD MARCUSSEN FOR THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. WHICH IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THE CREATION OF THE
BE TO LICENSE LATE HAVE SOUGHT
AMENDMENTS UNDER EXISTING LAW
FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE AN
ELECTRICIAN PERFORMING THE
ELECTRICAL WORK DESCRIBED IN SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE WOULD BE
REQUIRED. IF A PLOY BY A C. TEN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTOR. TO HAVE
NOT LESS THAN FOUR THOUSAND
HOURS OF ON THE JOB TRAINING AT
LEAST FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY HOURS
OF CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. AND
PASSED THE STATE'S
COMPREHENSIVE EXAM ON
ELECTRICAL PRACTICE. BUT
WORKERS EMPLOYED BY THE NEW E
TO LICENSE WOULD HAVE NO
SIMILAR REQUIREMENT. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LIQUOR XIN
CERTIFICATION AND MODIFIED OVER
THE YEARS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
FROM POOR WORKMANSHIP PLAN
QUALIFIED WORKERS. INSTALLING
IN MODIFYING ELECTRICAL
INSTALLATIONS. UNFORTUNATELY SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE FAILS TO
ADEQUATELY PROTECT CONSUMERS NO
HOMEOWNERS. BECAUSE IT IS DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE USE OF
CERTIFIED ELECTRICIAN'S. WE
COULD BELIEVE STATE OF THE BE
TO CONTRACTOR WILL PERFORM ANY
ELECTRICAL WORK IT SHOULD BE
DONE BY A CERTIFIED ELECTRICITY
OR- THEY SHOULD BE PROHIBITED
FROM PERFORMING ELECTRICAL
WORK. LIKE TO BUILD US FOR FIRE
PROTECTION AS BEST ABATEMENT
AND WILL TROLLING. WE HAVE BEEN
IN TOUCH WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF
THE CSL BE ANOTHER INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES ABOUT WEEK IS
CONCERNED. BUT AT THIS POINT WE
CAN MUST OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SOME. ADVANCE
THE BILL SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATORS OR ANYBODY
ELSE IN LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE. YES OVER LINE ONE HUNDRED
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
TWELVE. I'M ACTUALLY IN COURT
BECAUSE THE OWNERS ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH MISS STONE AN ELSE
OPERATOR. NOT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU PRESIDENT THANK YOU
OPERATOR FOR YOUR WONDERFUL
PATIENTS AND GOOD WORK TODAY
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. HI CENTER MCGUIRE
READY GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AT MISTER CHAIR WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
INJURE TEAM FOR YOUR WORK I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DOLLARS
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP NOW IN OVER THE
PAST MANY YEARS ON ALL ISSUES
OF THE REBUILD. IN IS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL- IN ON
BEHALF OF FIRE SURVIVORS WHO TO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY THANK
YOU CENTER REQUIRE AND I WANT
TO I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES- WILL
AGREE THAT THERE'S BEEN NO
GREATER LEE GET LEADER IN THE
NORTH BAY- THAN THAN YOU AND
THE AND THE AND THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE THE BE CONNECTED TO
YOUR COMMUNITY AND THE THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO REBUILD IT.
THIS LEGISLATION IS A NATURAL
PART OF THE BROADER PACKAGE
THAT YOU OF LATE ON A FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AN- HAS OUR
DEEP APPRECIATION AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY WITH THAT I
KNOWLEDGE OF MOTION FROM
SENATOR PANT TO MOVE THE BILL
IS THIS- DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO BUY. SHE
COULD HERE. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE TURN
MICROPHONE. ON AS ELEVEN A NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER BY. USER
I. CHIANG BY. BEING AYE
ARCHULETA. HI FOR CHILL OUT I'D
DODD. AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI
AYE. AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL HI.
WELL I LEYVA BY. LEVI I CAN
FIGHT. AND I WILL HI. TOLD BY.
THE MEASURE HAS NINE BUT THE
BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER MCGUIRE.
BEST OF LUCK GOING FORWARD.
PART MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I THINK THAT'S THE
LAST BILL. WELL MAYBE THERE'S
ANOTHER ONE HERE. OKAY GIVE
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE ITEM NUMBER
SIX IT'S- AS TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD CENTER
DOT NICE TO SEE YOU. WELL NICE
TO SEE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE CHAIR TO STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN
INCORPORATING THESE- HEAVILY
NEGOTIATOR AUTHOR MEMBERS INTO
THE BILL. SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN IT WOULD PROMOTE. A
COLLABORATIVE MODEL OF PATIENT
CARE. FOR CERTIFIED- CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES AND PHYSICIANS.
MY AIM IS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE FOR CHILDBIRTH BY REMOVING
THE REQUIREMENT. THAT A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE SECURE
THE PERMISSION OF A PHYSICIAN
IN ORDER TO PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS REQUIREMENT
DOES NOT PROMOTE TEAM BASED
CARE HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE SAFETY OR QUALITY OF
CARE IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
ATTAIN IN RESULTS- IN REDUCED
ACCESS TO BIRTHING WOMEN.
SUPERVISION DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
ANYMORE IT'S NOT TO FIGHT A
CALIFORNIA STATUTE THAT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE POSITION TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT EXAMINE THE
PATIENT SIDE TO REVIEW ANY
CHARTS OR OVERSEE PATIENT CARE.
IN ANY WAY. IN FACT A RECENT L.
EIGHT REPORT LA- REPORT FOUND
THE CALIFORNIA SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENTS FOR NURSE MIDWIVES
IS UNLIKELY TO IMPROVE SAFETY
AND QUALITY FOR LOW RISK
PREGNANCIES AND BIRTHS THEIR
WORK THAT ARE WITH IN THE C. N.
M. SCOPE. THIS LAW HAS RESULTED
IN CONCENTRATING NURSE MIDWIVES
IN GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WERE
PHYSICIANS PRACTICE. PHYSICALLY
PRACTICE REDUCING ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL COUNTIES
WHICH HAVE BECOME MATERNITY
DESERT'S IT IS MARGINALIZED
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. THERE
NINE COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THE
DO NOT HAVE AN OBGYN. MODOC
TRINITY GLAND COLUSA SIERRA
YUBA MONNOW ALPINE IN MARIPOSA.
IN ADDITION TO THESE MATERNITY
DESERT'S IN NOT WITHSTANDING
CALIFORNIA HAVING MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN REDUCING MATERNAL
MORTALITY. RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN OUTCOMES PERSIST BLACK IN
INDIGENOUS WOMEN REMAIN THREE
TO FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY TO DIE
FROM PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES.
THAN WHITE WOMEN. THERE'S A
DIRECT LINK BETWEEN RACE AND
ACCESS TO MATERNITY CARE
NATIONWIDE. THIS IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM REQUIRING MULTIPLE
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES IN ORDER
TO TURN THE TIDE. IMPROVING
ACCESS TO NURSE MIDWIFERY CARE
HAS BEEN NAMED BY LEADING
ORGANIZATIONS. SUCH AS THE
MARCH OF DIMES THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AS ONE OF THESE
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES IN
ADDRESSING THESE RACIAL
DISPARITIES. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT ANOTHER BENEFIT OF
NURSE MIDWIFERY. IS CARE IS
LOWER COST A STUDY SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA. HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION SHOWS THAT
INCREASING THE PERCENTAGE OF
PREGNANCIES WITH MIDWIFE LED
CARE FROM THE CURRENT LEVEL OF
ABOUT 9% 220% OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. COULD RESULT IN A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR IN COST SAVINGS
IN THIRTY THOUSAND FEWER
PRETERM BIRTHS. LASTLY I WISH
TO POINT OUT THE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF ONLY FOUR STATES IN THE
NATION. PLEASE REPEAT THAT ONE
OF FOUR STATES IN THE NATION
THAT STILL REQUIRES PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION IN ORDER FOR NURSE
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE ANALYSIS
IDENTIFIES AMENDMENTS THAT I AM
OFFERING AND ACCEPTING. THESE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY INTENT
LANGUAGE AND ADDRESS THE MAKE
UP OF NURSE MIDWIFERY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT PROVIDES
GUIDANCE TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING REGARDING
PRACTICE PROTOCOLS AND
GUIDELINES FOR THE CNN'S. THERE
ARE STILL A FEW OUTSTANDING
ISSUES WE ARE WORKING ON WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN RESOLVE THE SAYS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. IT ALSO
IS ALSO RAISES POLICY QUESTIONS
THAT WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS IN STATUTE. AND
I COMMIT TO ADDRESSING THESE AS
WELL. WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE IS HOLLY
SMITH A PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT
FROM THE CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION. AND
DOCTOR AND STORE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DIED TO AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU BOTH OF YOUR
WITNESSES ARE AVAILABLE ON THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR. BY GAS TO
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR HOLLY
SMITH AND DOCTOR AND STORE
PLEASE. YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS HOLLY SMITH I AM THE
HEALTH QUALITY CARE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION MY CURRENT WORK IS
THAT THEY CONSULTANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MATERNAL QUALITY
CARE COLLABORATIVE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAVE PLAYED A
KEY ROLE IN REDUCING MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND MORBIDITY STATE.
FIRST OF THAT ABOUT NURSE
MIDWIVES NURSE MIDWIVES ARE
MASTERS OR DOCTORAL RETRAIN
REGISTERED NURSES WITH ADVANCED
TRAINING IN THE GROCERY WE CAN
ONLY ATTEND AT LEAST FIFTY
THOUSAND PER PER YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA WITH 97% OF THOSE
HAPPENING IN THE HOSPITAL
PUTTING IN ABOUT 2% OF THOSE.
ATTENDING BURST IN BIRTH
CENTERS FOR THE HOME I TRAINED
AT GEORGETOWN MY COLLEAGUES
TRAINED AT UCSF YALE COLUMBIA
YOU CAN JUST TO NAME A FEW IF
IT SOUNDS LIKE I'M TRYING TO
PROVE THE EIGHTEEN QUALITY OF
THE TRAINING OCCURS THAT LIVES
UP BECAUSE I AM. IT REMAINS A
CONSTANT STRUGGLE FOR ALL
MIDWIVES WORLDWIDE TO PROVE OUR
WORK DESPITE THE STUDIES
SHOWING THAT THE WELL BEING OF
MOTHERS AND BABIES. WHERE AT IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR MATE. HE. IN
MORTALITY ARE ALL WE DO SHE
INTEGRATION OF NURSING HAS
NEVER BEEN MORE IMPORTANT NOW
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE SHE
RACIAL DESPAIR IN MATERNAL AND
INFANT. THE CURRENTLY HAVE TO
GET SHORT OF UP. THE DATA ON
REMOVED OF IS REVIEW THAT HE
SHOWED THAT STATE WHERE THERE
ARE INTO MY THAT CAN NOT SUPER
MODELS OF CARE HAVE LOWER GREAT
TO SECTARIAN BUDGETARY
INFECTION CREATURE BIRTH LOW
WEIGHT INTO IN YOUR NATAL THAT
SENATORS SB ONE THREE SO IS NOT
A MIDWAY GOING IT ALONE IN FACT
THIS BILL COULD FACE GARDEN
PLACE BUT DON'T CURRENT EXISTS
WITH THE PROVISION THIS BILL
MANDATE COLLAB TO BASED CARE
WITH TAX CALL. THANK HAS REAL
TODAY TRY HOW CARE DELIVER
ANDERSON ARE POOR TO THE GAP IN
IMPROVE OUT THANK YOU URGE YOUR.
VERY GOOD DOCTORS. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M DOCTOR IN STORE ABOARD
CERTIFIED OB YOU WHY A FOR OF
THE CALL OF US AND A CALL. I
RECEIVED MY INDEED FROM MEDIC
COLLEGE OF DID BY RED AT WASH
AND IN ST LOUIS I'M ABOUT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AT HARVARD SCHOOL
PUBLIC HEALTH I'VE BEEN A
PHYSICIAN THIRTY YEARS AND I'VE
FOR WITH MIDDLE FOR THEM OF
THAT TIME. I'VE ALSO SERVED IN
BERMAN ON THIS OF BY COMMITTEE
TO THE LICENSE REQUIRE AND
STUFF BUT PROP FOR LIKE BUT WHY
AND BERMAN. I CURRENTLY WORK AT
SATURDAY THIS WHERE WE HAVEN'T
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE OF
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES AND
DOCTORS WITH EXCELLENT
COMMUNICATION OUTSTANDING
OUTCOME. MAY ARE COME. TO FIT.
AND ARE. IN NORMAL. THEY IT
WOULD YOU AND TO PROVIDE THE
CARE FROM WE AS POSITIONS ARE
SPECIALLY TRAINED WHICH
INCLUDES COMPLICATED OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY. SENATOR DODD
SPOKE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS
A MATERNITY CRISIS WITH NOT
ENOUGH DID PHYSICIAN AVAILABLE
TO PROVIDE ARE NEEDED CARE. IN
OTHER STATES FROM ADVISED DON'T
PRACTICE UNDER SUPERVISION
THERE'S A MUCH HIGHER
PROPORTION A RURAL HOSPITALS
WITHIN I'M ATTENDED BURNS.
REMOVING I HEALTH WOULD ALLOW
VIETNAM PROVIDE CARE. IN OUR
UNDERSERVED AREAS. I WORK IN
STATE MIDWIFERY IS NOT DEPEND
PRACTICE. I REALLY HAVEN'T SEEN
DID IN THE CALL OF MOBILE
PRACTICE IN PLACE WHERE SHE-
LIMIT DO NOT EXIST. IT HAS BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE THAT CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES PRACTICE WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE OF CARE AND
CONSULTANT PROPERLY FOR
COLLABORATION OR TRANSFER OF
CARE. IN THE INTEREST OF LOWER
COST LOWER INTERVENTIONS LOWERS.
SECTION RIGHT EXPANDED ACCESS
TO CARE AND I HOPE HAPPIER
CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
WRITTEN BY THE OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO TESTIFIED TO PROVIDE
THEIR NAME AND THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEY'RE
INDICATION SUPPORT FOR START
THOSE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
I SEE A HAND UP SO PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE. DONNA HARRIS
CHIEF THE LEGISLATION FOR THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE REGISTERED
NURSES. AND I LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE HAS VOTED TO APPROVE
AND SUPPORT. SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM IT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. SEE NO HAN
DOUBLE UNTIL THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE TWENTY FORTY SO WE'LL GO TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES OPERATOR IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE. AT
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD COULD THEY
PLEASE SO INDICATE. LATEST TIME
IN FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY A. INGRAM ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR NEXT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KERA
MALOOF VERY I AM NOT REGISTERED
NURSES AND CERTIFIED NURSE. AND
SACRAMENTO. AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
OPERATOR HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE
HAVE ON THE LINE WAITING. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ON FOR THIS
ONE. A LOT OKAY ALL RIGHT HI I
CHAU INTO MY RECORDS YOUR
THIRTY FOUR SO HE'S WELL LET
EVERYBODY KNOW WE'RE GONNA TRY
TO PROCESS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
OPERATE HERE SO YOU COULD JUST
TAKE IT AWAY AND DISCO ONE
AFTER THE OTHER POLICE AND SO
WE CAN HEAR THEIR NAME REALLY
ATION AND THEIR EDUCATION
SUPPORT PLEASE. REAL GOOD
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN JOHN'S I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE AND
WOMEN'S HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER DAVIS CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE CELL.
ONE SEVENTEEN YEAR OPEN. FIND
ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE ON MUTE.
WE WILL I NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I'M MY NAME IS ROSE
ANNA DAVIS I'M A LICENSED
MIDWIFE AND PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIANS OF LIFE MIDWIVES
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA LICENSE YOUR
LIVES WE SUPPORT THE MOBILE. OF
PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION BUT HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LAW RIGHTS
OF PREGNANT PEOPLE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS SIGN MANAGE TO PROTECT
THE TURN A LOT OF TIME AND
ACCESS TO ESPECIALLY THOSE
IMPACT BY EMERGENCY. SITUATIONS
SUCH AS KOBE. NINETEEN WE WILL
I ONE THIRTY THREE GOING. ONE
THIRTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON TO ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE ON MUTE. WE WILL
GO TO ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
FORWARD. OKAY THE DIFFICULT YOU
GIVE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE COMMUNICATE. I'M NOT
HEARD BUT I DID TERRY LAMBERT
NAPA CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE MAP YOUR COMPARED MOST
RECENTLY AT THAT THE GENERAL
YOU YEAH THAT STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF AT BE ONE TWO
THREE GREAT THANK YOU VERY
UPPER NEXT CALLER THIS IS IN
SOME. OF TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE NAME AFFILIATION AND
EDUCATION SUPPORT GO AHEAD.
NINETY SO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
NINETY SO HI THIS IS LALIT BAHL
CHEN THANK YOU CAN AND THAT
BILLION DOLLARS THE ANIME I AND
TRY THE OF. THAT THE ONE TWO
THREE NINE BY NATIONAL I. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTH FIVE GOING. HI MY NAME IS
SHERRY EGAN CIRCA NURSING IN
PASSWORD IN PASS IN ALL THE HOW.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY FOUR HERE LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS A FULL BLOWN WITH
YOU I WANTED ACTION COSTA FROM
WHERE YOU. ORDER AT THE. THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU ARE LYING ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR OPEN. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH YOU HEAR ME. YEAH HELLO
THIS WEEKEND PLEASE LEARN HOW.
I EXECUTIVE OF HE ORGANISER THE
TREE FOR THIS AND I'M DRUNK
AFFORDABLE ONE TWO THREE THANK
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING I ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MONICA VIA MISTER
NURSING AND IN LOS. AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA SMITH
A IN SUPPORT OF TOP THIRTY. ONE
EIGHT FIVE YOU ARE OLD. HI HER
BACK FROM THE FOR A CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PROUD ON TO THE BILL AND
ARE JUST PORT THANK YOU. AND
LINE WILL TWENTY FOR PLEASE
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BETHANY MY
MUCH NURSE MAY ENGLAND HEALTH
NURSE PRACTITIONER NAMED
SUPPORT AT ALL. TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. ONE SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN
TO GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
NANCY BLUE AND I'M A CO THAT
OCCUR IN THAT IS FOLLOWING
QUICKLY OF THE OF THE ACT HE.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS MELISSA MANZINI I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND HAVE BEEN
UNDER THE CARE OF NURSE
MIDWIVES TWENTY PREGNANCIES AND
THE TRUNK THE COURT OF THE
MEASURE. ONE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME OF THE
NIGHT AT CS AT MEAL WITH
CALIFORNIA AND THAT THE NOT FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TALK
EIGHTY SEVEN. ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS THIS IS KIRK
BLACKBURN- BE HAPPY IN THE
NURSES ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH ACT IN SUPPORT.
AND ONE FORTY YOU ARE NOW ALL
BUT- ELIZABETH MET THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER OF THE BIRTH
CENTER IN SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA
I AM A CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE
AND SUPPORT SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THAT SHAPING CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
APPEARING IT'LL NURSE AT UCSF
BY WORK WITH OBGYN AND
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN THANK. NINE ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CALLIE- MEN AND I'M
A PARALEGAL NURSE ALSO AT UCSF
WORKING WITH THE TRADITION IN
THE CRACKS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT I SPEAK ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR JADE
NOBLE FAMILY TRIED DISCUSSION.
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORT- SB ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS EMILY DAHLE AND AFTER
ACTUAL COMMUNITY IN NORTHERN
ORANGE COUNTY WE SERVE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED OR SO ALL IN A
VERY SERVE POPULATION WITH ME
BUT- LIFTING TO PROVISION COULD
HELP YOU ACCESS TO MANY THAT
WERE SERVING IN THIS COMMUNITY
SO WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SANDRA
GOODMAN I'M A CERTIFIED MIDWIFE
AND WOMEN'S HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BE TO TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
REBECCA LEADERSHIP CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES YES. I AM A REGISTERED
NURSE I'M A LABOR AND DELIVERY
NURSE THAT IN SANTA BARBARA AND
I SUPPORT AT THE ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JODY CANNON BURN I AM A FULL
SPECTRUM DOULA AND REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ADVOCATE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I AM. I AM HOLDING
NO ONE TWO THREE THOUSAND AND
LACKEY AND ACT AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE TOP RESTRICTIONS ON
FREEDOM OF PRACTICE ON BEHALF
IAN AND THEN BRING PEOPLE. TO
THE CARE PROVIDERS AND THEIR
BURNING. THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS SONYA
YOUNG I DON I AM THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S HEALTH
PROJECT AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL
ALIGN ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI YES MY NAME IS
REBECCA THIS HANDSOME A CLIENT
IN A PHARMACY TECHNICIAN AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. X. DESIGNED
ONE SEVENTEEN. ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR OPEN. ONE SEVENTEEN. I'M
MOVING ALONG A LITTLE LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
CLEAR YOU ONLY ONE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE ABOUT
TEN MORE. LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAPITAL
GOVERNOR MARK THE RECLINER BY
CLICKING CARE HEALTH CENTERS IN
YOLO OUNTY CALIFORNIA. THE
TWENTY YEAR PROVIDING FOR THE
ARE YOU. AND UNINSURED AND I
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. FIND
ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS DOCTOR STEPHANIE FREE
THEN I'M A PHYSICIAN AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA GO
BACK BURGE THE GENERAL.
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTY
SEVEN. LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE GET
HERE YOU PLAY LIKE HELPING. HI
MY HONEST ABOUT THEIR NINE IN
THAT GAME I MEAN. WE ARE ALL.
TIME CRAZINESS AND THEREFORE.
YEAH. ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY NINE OUR I'M AN
OBSTETRICIAN GYNECOLOGIST
DIVISION AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT U. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY NINE CAN YOU HEAR US FOR
THIRTY SEVEN. I CAN HEAR YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD MY NAME IS HANA COPY
EIGHT I AM A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE IN GENERAL THE
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE. ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
PASCAL AND THE PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR INNOVATING EDUCATION AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M GONNA THE
COURT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR BACK A GRIFFIN I LOOK AT
THE BIXBY CENTER FOR GLOBAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AT U. C. L.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU TALK.
FIND TO- TO YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M THINKING I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE THAT
COMMUNICATE HEALTH CENTERS IN
THE WITH CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. NOW WE WILL GO TO
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS BRANDY HOW
DUNKIN I AM A FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE IT. STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINETY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. DOCTOR MELISSA ROSENSTEIN
I'M A MATERNAL FETAL MEDICINE
SPECIALIST AT UCSF AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. ONE THIRTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOW SHE
SOUTH ON BLU AND I AM- VERY
HAPPY SATISFIED CLIENT OF A
MIDWIFE AND I DO- WIDESPREAD
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED I APPRECIATE ALL THE
AMAZING MIDWIVES WHO ARE OUT
YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT THE BILL
AND WE STRONG STRONG SUPPORT
REMOVING POSITION APPROVAL BUT
UNLESS OTHERWISE AMENDED. LIKE
WHO IS OVER FORTY YEARS OLD
HAVING A SECOND CHILD WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEEMED INELIGIBLE
FROM THE BLACK CARE AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE MADE BETWEEN MY
PROVIDER MY MIDWIFE AND I AM
NOT I THINK FROM A VERY
REGULATION INTO THE THANK YOU.
LINE ONE A SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS RACHEL AND I AM THAT
IF NURSE MIDWIVES AND WOMEN
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER AND
ACCU HEALTH CENTER AND OKAY CAL.
AND I'D STRONGLY AT THE TOP.
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE NINETY FOUR
HERE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
BUT A LOCAL TEACHER TRAINING
LIKE EARLY ABORTION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH THE
TRAINING PROGRAM IN THE BAY
AREA. NOW WHAT. MY TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE CALL. HI MY
NAME IS CRITICAL AGAIN I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE WHO
GAVE IT CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT SB. SEVEN THANK YOU
NEXT IS ONE NINETY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS CARLY AND BROWN IN THE
LAKE AND MIDWIVES FACCHINI CARE
HEALTH CENTERS DOES BOOK TOO
DIFFICULT FAMILY MATERNITY
CENTER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT B. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THANKS AND WE WERE GOING TO
NINETEEN THANK YOU. MAKING YOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- YES NOT
ROMANTIC DAVIS AGAIN- I JUST
WANTED TO GO ON RECORD AS
SAYING THAT I THINK CALL AND
TOOK A LEFT MANDATE- AND WE ARE
WORKING. WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
ON MAKING OF AMENDMENT TO.
RESTRICTION FOR CERTAIN. PEOPLE
THANK YOU. AND NEXT IS ONE TWO
ZERO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ELLEN ARE DRY I'M A PROFESSOR
AT UCF PENDANT OBGYN WHO
PRACTICE THAT AND GET THE CODE
GENERAL- I ALSO RECEIVED MY OWN
PRENATAL CARE WITH. CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE AS I HAVE THAT
THEY DID MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TWO TWENTY ONE YEAR OPEN.
I THEIR ACT LISTEN I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE AT
COMMUNITY MEMORIAL IN VENTURA.
AND I GET. JOHN LEE THE COURT
AT THE. ONE TWO THREE. TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
ELEVEN. I LIKE I JUST RETIRED
FROM I THIRTY YEAR LEADERSHIP
WELL WITH A LOCAL NATIONAL AND-
REGIONAL- COMPONENT- FOR A VERY
LARGE HMO AND FOUND THE
RESTRICTIVE LANGUAGE AND THE
LOOK OF THAT SUPERVISION PART
OF OUR- GUIDANCE IN CALIFORNIA
TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO DEAL
WITH I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND LET ME REMIND YOU.
CALLERS THAT WERE TO A CON OR
TAKING IN AS A H. IN SOME THE
TESTIMONY HAS BEEN COMPLETED.
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
SUGGEST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION OPERATOR PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU I WILL GO
TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME AND TYLER I AM A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE WOULD
COMMUNICATE HEALTH CLINICS AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TWO TWENTY SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ERIN CAME ON I'M A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES IN DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL TO LINE ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
REGAN WATSON I'M A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE- MAKERS ARE
PERMANENT IN SACRAMENTO AND I
COMMUNICATE OPEN HEARD IN YOUR
ACCOUNT. AND I A STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO
I THE PARTICIPANTS ARE CUED UP
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD OKAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
OPPOSITION. TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA FIRST INVITE THOSE HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE SO
INDICATE. GOOD MORNING MR TURN
MEMBERS MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
WHICH IS ONLY BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS BEFORE YOU AREN'T
THE TOTALITY OF WORK WHICH WE
NEED TO DO ON THIS BILL. WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS ON THIS LANGUAGE
AND HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON AMENDMENTS. LEAVING
ONLY A FEW OUTSTANDING ISSUES
TO RESOLVE. NAMELY ENSURING A
PATIENT SAFETY DURING. THE
BACKS IS A TOP PRIORITY AND
MAKING SURE THIS THE AND I'M
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
TRAINING. AND PERFORMS THESE IN
THE SAFEST ENVIRONMENT POSSIBLE
IS WHAT WE'RE STILL WORKING ON.
AS WELL AS THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF PHILIP PHYSICIAN
COLLABORATION FOR FURNISHING
DRUGS. OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
THESE ISSUES RESOLVED IN TIME
FOR THE FLOOR AND WILL CONTINUE
TO KEEP YOU UPDATED ON
pTHERE ARE APPRECIATION OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE IN THIS
BILL. WHERE THE GT'S PERFORMED
BY THE SEA AND MS WHETHER IN A
COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT OR
INDEPENDENTLY. ARE
APPROPRIATELY ALIGNED THEIR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. AND
WHERE THE LIBERAL POSITION OF
MEN IS CLEARLY DEFINED. WE HAVE
THE COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO
SERVE. THIS FRAMEWORK AS IT
CONTINUES OTHERS. CONSIDERS
OTHERS BILLS THAT COME BEFORE
IT. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BRENT SPENCER WITH
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN STIR
SHOULD NINE. WELL APPRECIATE
THE MINUTES ADOPTED PREVIOUSLY
IN TODAY WE MUST STILL MAINTAIN
OPPOSE LAST POSITION MAYBE
TWELVE THREE SEVEN. THIS
POSITION BASED ON MANY OF THE
SAME REASONS MUCH ABOUT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM C. MAY. AS WELL
AS INCLUDING SOME ADDITIONAL
COLLECTION OF PROPERTY THAT
INFORMATION. POLICIES RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR THE OTHER
STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR ALL
THEIR WORK WITH US AS FAR. AND
THE FOURTEEN OUR DISCUSSIONS AS
WE NAVIGATE THE MECHANICS OF
THIS PROPOSED REVISED
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PHYSICIAN
AND A CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE.
AGAIN TRULY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND I'M HOPEFUL FOR
RESOLUTION. BUT TELL THAN. A
**** DISTRICT NINE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED TO LESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME VERY GOOD ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TINO FOR THEIR HANDS UP
WE'RE GOING TO GO LIVE TOLD
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
SO WE'RE GOING TO SKIP THAT.
AND HAD TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN A PLEASE SO INDICATE. AND
PLEASE DO THAT BY- PUT PRESSING
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND ONE
SEVENTEEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOW WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I AM I ACTUALLY
GOT SKIPPED OVER IN THAT
SECTION FOR SUPPORT- SO ARE YOU
WORK- AT THE ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN MANY YOUNG DAHLE I WORK
AS A LABOR DELIVERY ARE AND IN
OUR HOSPITAL MOM BEACH I'M A
STUDENT MIDWIFE I'VE BEEN A
RECIPIENT OF BOTH PHYSICIAN
CARE. AND MIDWIFERY CARE AND I
SUPPORT AT THE ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN VERY GOOD GLAD WE GOT
YEAH OPERATOR CONTINUE PLEASE.
LINE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NINETY YOUR OPEN. WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR NAME
IN A FILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE. MY NAME IS
LEILANI WHEN I'M ON THE BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THREE
WE REPRESENT OVER FIVE THOUSAND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED MEDICAL
RESTRICTIONS SHOULD BE HANDLED
AND REGULATORY COMMITTEE NOT
AND LEGISLATION MEDICAL
RESTRICTIONS ARE UNREASONABLE
DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND- FOR
WOMEN WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
RIGHT OUT OF MIDWIFERY CARE.
THE PROPOSED- PATERNALISTIC
RESTRICTION SHOULD NOT BE
FOSSILIZED INTO LAW I MYSELF
WITHIN WITHOUT OF MY LAST TWO
NORMAL HEALTHY PAYMENT BECAUSE
I WAS OVER FORTY THE DECISION
SHOULD BE BETWEEN A PREGNANT
PERSON ON THEIR CARE PROVIDER
AFTER WEIGHING THE PERSONAL
RISK AND COULD TUITION AS A
MATTER OF YOU COMING. INTEREST
REALLY HAVE OR MINUTE BREAK
WE'RE SEEING OF COLD NINETEEN
MORE WHEN ARE CHOOSING TO HOME
BIRTH DOUBLY HOT WHEN YOU MORE
OPTIONS AND WE NEED TO OPEN UP
ACCESS OF PUTTING RESTRICTIONS
INTO LAW. THANK. YOU Q. AND A
THAT DOES TOTAL THE THREE IN A-
THAT THE MAKES IT PALATABLE
SIDE WOULD LIKE TO ASK. ANY
OTHER. IN OPPOSITION TO JUST
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOU
PHILLY. AND THAT UP. OPERATOR
PLEASE PLEASE CONTINUE. LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FORTY FIVE YOU'RE ON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WILL TRY ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
ONE FORTY FIVE COULD. ONE FORTY
FIVE- SORRY I GOT CONFUSED
EARLIER ON THE PORT SIDE I AM
GUILTY CANNIBAL FULL SPECTRUM
DO LAND I AM OPPOSED TO ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED FOR
REMOVAL OF RESTRICTIONS SHOULD
BE IN AN- AMBER THAN PEOPLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE
EXCUSE ME ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY FOUR YEAR
OPEN. ALONG WITH NEXT FOUR ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE CALL AT. ONE
SEVENTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. I DON'T
THINK THAT. THAT IS YOU I'M
SORRY I AM THINKING IT NEARLY
THIRTY FIVE YEARS THE ONE
THOUSAND PRACTITIONER AND I
ACTUALLY GOT IT OVER TO SUPPORT
I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. PARTS PLEASE AND WE
WILL. THANK YOU WE WILL GO. TO
LINE. MOMENT WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YEAH GO AHEAD PLEASE. CAN
YOU HEAR ME MY NAME'S ELIZABETH
FADER AND CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES IN HARBOUR CITY
CALIFORNIA AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO SEVEN
VERY MUCH. LIKE TO LET
EVERYBODY IN THE PHONE LINES NO
THEY WERE ONLY DEALING WITH
OPPOSITION AT THE POINT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND THE HEARING
SO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT WE'VE GIVEN OU
THE OPPORTUNITY EARLIER BUT IT
AT OPERATOR IF YOU CAN CONTINUE
ON AND AGAIN THIS IS THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. PLEASE CONTINUE.
TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO WILL GO TO ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS ONE THREE.
SIX YEAH HELLO. YES WHAT WOULD
YOUR NAME PLEASE AND YOUR
AFFILIATION WITH ANY. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE SPEAK UP A
GO AHEAD. OKAY MY NAME ME THREE
AND THREE THIRTY BY NOT THAT
WIDE NOT PETITION ARE I'M
WORKING WITH A BOW THEY CRACKED
THE PERMANENT BANK AND I'M
CONCEPT FOR EIGHT THE SP. ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL I
pMUCH OPERATE GOING TO THE NEXT
ONE PLEASE. THIS IS ONLY TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION PLEASE IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
YOUR WANT TO REGISTER SUPPORT
THAT MOMENT IS GONE SO WE'RE
ONLY DEALING WITH OPPOSITION
THAT PLEASE. GO AHEAD OPERATOR.
LINE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY AND MY NAME IS
TERRY FOR YOU AND THE FOR
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES FOR ACTIVATION MIDWIFE
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE FIVE
THOUSAND CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND I OPPOSE THE LAST
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. HELLO LINE TWO
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY THIS IS KATHLEEN BELL THERE
I AM SORRY THAT I AM CALLING IN
BUT I AT THIS TIME BUT I HAD
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION. I AM A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE SENATOR
DODD DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT OKAY THE JUSTICE AND
EQUITY IN MATERNITY CARE ACT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. ALL NEXT WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF LINE ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY ONE
SIXTY SIX FOR ONE IS OPEN. AND
JUST A MOMENT WE'LL GO TO THE
NEXT LINE. AND LINE ONE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I. TEN PART ME LINE
ONE FIFTY FOUR- IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN PLAYS. ALL RIGHT JUST A
MOMENT LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR. I
MODEL IN WHITE CENTER AND A
LIFE LINE AND A MEDICAL
PROVIDER IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS AMENDED
IT REMOVE RESTRICTIONS ON
MIDWIVES AND PLACE OF BIRTH AND
BURKE. OPERATOR THERE ANY UP
FOR PHONE LINES DEPENDING. JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. WHEN WE
NEEDING A. OPERATORS AT TECH
INCLUDE OUR OUR PHONE INS AND
THIS BILL. I AM PARDON ME NO
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE I
APOLOGIZE OUR NEXT LINE IS
LINED LINE TO THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LYNN DONNELLY I AM THE- THE
HEALTH POLICY VICE CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE OPERATOR.
OUR NEXT OUR NEXT COMES FROM
THE LINE APPLYING TO ALL FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY THERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
FROM OUR MORGAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
OAKLAND AND A BIRD FOUNDATION
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE ALL.
IF THE FAMILY IS IN PARTICULAR
FAMILIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES- WHILE WE NEED
TO SYNDICATE YOU'RE PUTTING ON
THE PLAY ON THE BILL PLEASE
MA'AM. YES THE PROVISION OF THE
BILL IS THE QUESTION I MEAN I
MONTH THE PUBLIC THAT AS WITH
ME OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OPERATOR NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
TAX ARSONIST LINE ONE NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS JENNY
PAYKEL I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
ACTUALLY THE MIDWIVES AND I'M
ALSO ABOUT TO GIVE BIRTH FOR
THE FOURTH TIME WITH A LICENSE
OUT OF HOSPITAL MIDWIFE. AND
AYE OPPOSED THE SPELL A MUST
AMENDED TO REMOVE RESTRICTIONS
FOR LICENSE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF LINE
NINETY. ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHY NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. M. M. PARDON ME AGAIN
LINE NINETY IF YOU CAN HEAR ME
PLEASE RESPOND. TEN PART MAY
JUST A MOMENT. AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO THE LINE OF LINE UP TO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT HERE.
AND JUST AND AGAIN WE'RE GOING
TO LINE OF LYING TO TWENTY FOUR.
THE LINE SO. MY NAME IS MELINDA.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT. INTEL BASED
FOR THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
THANK YOU STRONG SUPPORT AT
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OPERATOR HOW MANY
WERE PHONE LINES ARE THERE AND
IN Q. WELL. WE HAD TO ALL RIGHT
VERY GOOD PLEASE CONTINUE. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE OF ONE ONE
SIXTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS THE
LAND I'M IN CAN HEAR ME I CAN'T
PLEASE. I AM AN INDEPENDENT
BIRTH DOULA I'M MOTHER OF A
THREE YEAR OLD SO I HAVE AND
REGULATE IT EDUCATIONAL CARRIER
AND THROUGH IDEA FOR ANYTHING
IN MY I WAS UNLESS-
RESTRICTIONS ARE OMITTED. SO
THAT AT INDIVIDUALS WITH I THE
APPLE OR ARE YOU ARE. ADMITTED
IN THE AMENDMENTS ARE ALLOWED
IF YOU READ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES THERE. PLEASE CONSIDER.
OPERATORS ANYBODY ELSE READY TO
TESTIFY ON THIS LEGISLATION S.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD. WE HAVE ONE FINAL
COMMENT FROM A LITTLE LINE OF-
THE LINE OF TWO FORTY THREE AND
IT WILL BE JUST A MOMENT. ONE
TWO FORTY ONE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS BJ SMELL I'M A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE AND I HEARD YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU OKAY OPERATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
YOUR GOOD WORK- WE'VE HEARD
FROM- WITNESSES IN FAVOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
MAKE THE MATTER BACK TO THE-
FOR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU- THE
CENTER DODD FOR- BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- YOU KNOW I'D-
CERTAINLY I THINK THAT IT IT'S
PROBABLY TO HAVE BEEN PRACTICED
FOR NURSE MIDWIVES IN
APPROPRIATE SETTINGS I
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
WHAT THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
THIS. PERSON COLLEGE OF OBGYN
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
BILL THE ISSUE I DID MY BRING
UP IS THAT- HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WHEN WE HAVE A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL THAT IS ACTING
INDEPENDENTLY WE WANTED TO BE
TRULY INDEPENDENT OKAY SO.
PHYSICIANS DENNIS OF TOM
INTEREST OTHERS- WHO CAN'T
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY ALSO
CALL ON CORPORATE ARE TO BE
SURE THAT OUT WHEN THEY MAKE
THEIR CLINICAL DECISIONS THEY
MAKE THEM THE BEST INTEREST OF
PATIENTS. NOT OF A PATIENT WHO-
IS THAT THEY MAY BE. BASICALLY
WITH A SAY THAT YOU CAN'T BE IN
THE POLIO A LOT OF FOR. RIGHT
YOU CAN WORK FOR SOMEONE YOUR
OWN PROFESSION- BUT WE DON'T
ALLOW. YOU TO ACCEPT FOUR ZERO-
SOME EXCEPTIONS LIKE THE STATE
GOVERNMENT OR SOMETHING. BUT
GENERALLY THAT'S TO INSURE WE
PROTECT PATIENTS WE KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC WE HAVE
SEEN SITUATIONS. IN OTHER
STATES WHERE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE UNDER
DEPLOY OF INSTITUTION- SOME.
I'VE BEEN EITHER SILENCE GOT
FIRED FOR SPEAKING OUT ABOUT-
FISHING CARE PRACTICES THAT
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT SO
BASICALLY GIANT SOUNDS HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL FROM DOING THAT SO
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
THAT- FOR IN THIS BILL- TO
ENSURE THAT ARE NEAR THESE
NURSE MIDWIVES WHO YOU'RE WITH.
YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO GET INTO PRACTICE THAT
WE SORT OF THE TRULY
INDEPENDENT THAT THEY ARE.
UNDER THE SAME CORPORATE BAR
THAT- THE OBGYN SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE COLLABORATING WITH-
TODAY WOULD BE IN THAT SAME
INDEPENDENT SITUATION- SO I
JUST WONDER WHETHER YOU'D BE
WILLING TO COMMIT TO. SOMETHING
THAT IN YOUR BILL TO UNDERSTAND
IN OUR PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
THAT'S NOT FROM THE PART OF THE
BILL. YES WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SENATOR- I THINK THAT'S A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM. THESE WERE NOT
INCREASING THEIR SCOPE. OF
PRACTICE TODAY THEY PRACTICE
MIDWIFERY WHICH IS- BY- STUDY-
BUT- THE MOST AFFORDABLE CARE-
YOU KNOW IN IN IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA. IT ALSO
DEFIES. THE TEAM BASED.
APPROACH WITH- DOCTORS THAT
THEY THE COOPERATION BETWEEN
THEM THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THE
COMMITTEE- WE'VE GOT HER FOR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS WE'VE NOT
HEARD ABOUT THIS FROM THE- DID
THE CM- CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- YOU
THE- ALSO WE PASSED AB FIVE SO
WE PUT THESE NURSES MIDWIVES.
HERE REAL PRECARIOUS POSITION
BECAUSE WITH AB FIVE THEY
CANNOT BE HIRED. AS A
CONSULTANT A CHIROPRACTOR'S
HOSPITALS THEY'RE PREVENTED AND
THEN HERE WITH CORPORATE BAR
THEY CAN'T BE EMPLOYED BY THE-
THINK WE FOR THOSE TWO REASONS.
I WOULD NOT CONSIDER I WOULD
CONSIDER THAT A HOSTILE
AMENDMENT OKAY WELL I
UNFORTUNATELY- PERSONAL IT'S
NOT HOSTILE WELL- A DIED I BEG
TO DIFFER I MEAN TO SAY YOU CAN
CERTAINLY HAVE. YOUR OWN
OPINION ABOUT I THINK THAT-
BECAUSE WE ARE I MEAN THE
ESSENCE OF THE BILL WHICH I DO
SUPPORT IS THAT WOULD GIVE
NURSE MIDWIVES. AND INTERPRET
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE RATE I
MEAN. CENTERS I THINK THAT YOU
POINTED OUT THAT- YOU KNOW TO
KEEP THEY CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
IT I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE IT.
THAT'S I BELIEVE IS THE PURPOSE
OF THE BILL AT THE SAME TIME I
THINK WE WANT TO SHARE THAT IN
THERE INDEPENDENCE AND AGAIN
IT'S THAT ACTUALLY DOESN'T.
ARTICLE PROVIDE DOESN'T PREVENT
AND A AN A PLAYMATE
RELATIONSHIP. OTHER PEOPLE AND
THEIR SAME SHE ALSO TELL UNDER-
MIDWIFE'S COULD HAVE OTHER
PERSON IN. REPORT EYE WORK THE
OTHER PERFECT WELL SELF. HE
THAT HAVE. AS DEPEND HELP
KNOWLES HOW THANK BY THE WAY
THE OP TO AYE ENDS WHO WOULD BE
WITH US DESCRIBED THIS BILL SO
I I'M SORRY THAT YOU'RE NOT TO
ENTER THAT BUT- YOU KNOW I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL WHAT WE CAN HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
INCONSIDERATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'VE CENTER CHIANG AND THEN
CENTER HEALTH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- THERE
MEANS A GOOD FAITH EFFORT BY
BOTH SIDES. OF THIS ISSUE TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND I'M
HOPING THAT THAT IS TRULY THE
CASE- I AM WILLING TO VOTE TO
MOVE THIS BILL ALONG. THE RIGHT
TO CHANGE MY BUT IF YOU.
THROUGH I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR FOR BRING THE BILL FOR.
THAT THANK YOU CENTER CENTER
HILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL UP IT IS A
LONG TIME IN COMING AND I
BELIEVE. THAT THE ISSUE THAT.
YOU'VE JUST PRESS RELATED TO
THE CORPORATE BAR I IT
SHOULDN'T APPLY TO THIS
PROFESSION. FRANKLY I DON'T
BELIEVE IT SHOULD. BE IT SHOULD
OF BE APPLIED TO ANY OF THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS- I THINK
THIS IS A- VERY APPROPRIATE-
USE OF. OF THE- OF THE ACT AND
I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
APPROPRIATE BILL HAPPY TO
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER HEALTH CENTER WILK.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I TO
SLOW YOU FOR TRYING TO FIND A
PATH FORWARD. I THINK WE'RE NOT
QUITE THERE YET BUT I AM
COMPANY YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
GET THERE SO I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
MY VOTE A RESERVE JUDGMENT. AS
TO THE FLOOR. BUT IT THIS IS A
NECESSARY. AGAIN THERE. THE
CENTER WILL CENTER ARCHULETA
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD FROM
PREVENTING THIS- WITH A NUMBER
OF SUPPORT DID YOU GET WE'VE
HEARD TODAY IT IT'S BEEN
AMAZING MY CONCERN WAS
EDUCATION WE ADDRESS AT MY
CONCERN WAS THE SUPERVISION AND
WHAT WITH PHYSICIANS WITH
ADDRESS THAT AND WE CERTAINLY
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
FINANCIALLY IT'S A PLUS PLUS-
FOR SO MANY ASPECTS OF OUR
SOCIETY. SO I BE- SUPPORTED I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING AFFORD
THANK YOU A GOOD ANY OTHER
MEMBER WISHES TO COMMENT A
READING OF ACCESS AND OR DIAPER
CLOSE. UNDER GOD AT. CLOSING
HIS CHARGES FOR THOSE PEOPLE
OUT THERE THEY'RE STILL
LISTENING TO THOSE- A LICENSED
NURSE MIDWIVES THAT- WORLD ON
THE PHONE OPPOSING THIS BILL. I
THINK A LOT OF THEIR OPPOSITION
IS MISUNDERSTOOD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS BILL- THE
SPONSORS NOR MYSELF INTENDED TO
BRING ANY REGULATIONS IN THIS
SPECIFIC BILL AGAINST THE NERD
THE LICENSED NURSE MIDWIVES
THIS IS A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE BILL. APPOINT A
CERTIFIED NURSE WIVES ONLY IT
IS WITH THIS THAT'S PART OF THE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE- I
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
BROUGHT FORWARD THAT WE NEED
TIME TO BE ABLE SIT IN FRONT OF
THEM. AND DISCUSS THIS HASH
THAT PORTION OF IT OUT SO I
COMMIT THAT WE WILL BE WORKING
ON THAT. BUT TO CLOSING
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT FORTY SIX
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE
SB TWELVE TO RESETTLE REMOVE
THE FOR THE PHYSICIAN
PERMISSION TO PRACTICE LAW. FOR
NURSE MIDWIVES PRACTICE LAW.-BACK TO SLUSH USUALLY BY IT
ALSO DEFINES TRUE COLLABORATIVE
CARE IS BETWEEN POSITIONS. AND
MIDWIVES IT CREATES THE
FOUNDATION FOR CONSULTATION CO
MANAGEMENT IN SEAMLESS TRANSFER
OF CARE WHEN WE NEEDED IT I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES. FOR
STATE HANGING IN THERE AND
REALLY NEGOTIATING IN GOOD
FAITH IN UNDER ANY WELL
COLLABORATION REALLY IS AND
WORKING WITH THE TALKS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. THAT
COLLABORATE IN GOING FORWARD SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
MOVED TO DO MUCH BETTER DODD
THANK YOU- THANK YOU INTO YOUR
AND ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. WE WERE IN RICH BY
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS AND
FEEDBACK I WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR DOT FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE. KNOWLEDGE CENTER
FEW ISSUES IS STILL NEED WORK
ALONG THE WAY. AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT- WITH UNDER YOUR
ABLE. STEWARDSHIP THAT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN THE BILL AS IT GOES
FORWARD AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
DAY. THAT I WOULD HAVE
KNOWLEDGE IN MOTION SENATOR
HILL- DO PASS AS AMENDED. AND
AS THE. WELL TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER HI. THERE I CHIANG HI. I
ARCHULETA HI VIRTUAL AT AYE
DODD AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
LEYVA BY YOU BY HAND. WILK HI
WELL I MEASURE HAS EIGHT VOTE
OKAY MEASURE HAS A VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT A TWO ZERO-
GRADUATION CENTER DOT. RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. SB TWELVE
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR BRADFORD
TO WELCOME HIM TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
CENTER BRADFORD COME FORWARD I
WANT TO NOTE THAT I'M TOLD THAT
WE HAVE A STOP AT TWELVE THIRTY
SO I WANT TO BE- MINDFUL OF
THAT AS WE MOVE THROUGH THESE
REMAINING BILL CENTER BRADFORD
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS ON HERE TO PUT. SB
TWELVE FORTY FOUR TO STREET FOR
MEASURE THAT. HELPS INCREASE
SAFETY IN THE CANNABIS CENTERS
INDUSTRIES PERSONALIZED OF
COVERT NINETEEN WERE-
CONSUMPTION AND SALES OF GONE
THROUGH THE ROOF HOW WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT PRODUCT
THAT IS REACHING CONSUMERS AS
SAFE AS WELL AS A THREE FOR THE
BUSINESS OUR COMMUNITY THAT'S
PROVIDING IT. CANNABIS IS NOW
ONE OF THE CENTRAL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN RECOGNIZED
DURING THIS CRISIS AND GIVES
MORE EVEN MORE REASON TO MAKE
SURE ONCE AGAIN THAT CONSUMERS
AND WORKERS ARE PROTECTED- IN
THIS INDUSTRY- EXIST EXISTING
LAW PREVENTS. MANY PUBLICATIONS
TO FROM TESTING CAMOS FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY PURPOSES-
THIS IS- PREVENT- GOOD ACTORS
FROM BEING COMFORTABLE- IF I
WILL PUT THEM AT A DISADVANTAGE
ESPECIALLY THE SMALL MINORITY
OF CASES AND BLOUSE A GOOD. IN
IMAGE THAT ARE BASED MANY. FOR
IS FROM SCHOOL FROM FED AID.
SUCH AS P. SO- THIS IS
COMMONSENSE ROGER AND I IT'S
SUPPORTED BY LA CITY ATTORNEY.
MICHAEL FEWER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTED I
BELIEVE I HAVE SERIOUSLYSHAW.
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY ATTORNEY
ITS REPORT. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD ALTHOUGH THE SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES- SYLVIA SOLELY
SHOT SHOULD BE ON THE LINE AND
WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
OPERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF FIVE
MISSED SHOTS ON THE LINE PLEASE.
YES PINE IS OPEN FOR ON ONE
MOMENT. IT. SHE IS ONLINE AND
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MA'AM.
SHARKS SHOP PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT WELL READY FOR HER
AND ASK IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I'LL SEE ANY
HANDS UP BY TWENTY FORTY UNTIL
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. ANY OTHER
FOLKS ON THE LINE BESIDE THE
SHOT THAT WANT TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION. THE
OPERATOR DEFINE THE SHOP PLEASE
LET HER KNOW THAT SHE'S WELCOME
TO TESTIFY AS SOON AS WE'RE
ABLE TO. IDENTIFY HER SHE IS.
SHE IS ON AN AIRLINE IS OPEN
THE SHOCKING USERS. ALRIGHT
WE'LL ALREADY PERMISSION MASTER
THE BODY HERE IN OPPOSITION. OF
THE LEGISLATION HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I SEE NO HANDS
FIVE TWENTY FORTY UNTIL THERE'S
NO ONE THERE SO IT ALSO LIKE TO
ASK IS AND THEY'RE ON THE PHONE
LINE IT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN FAVOR OR AGAINST THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE SO INDICATE.
THIS IS SB TWELVE FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. OPERATOR CAN
YOU AK IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE THAT THEY'D LIKE TO
TESTIFIED FAVOR AGAINST THIS
LEGISLATION. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TSTIFIED PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOTTOM LINE TO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO FIFTY FOUR. CAN YOU
HEAR US. ALL TRY LINE NINETY
NINE AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BELOW THAT THE DINNER FEEL ON
BEHALF OF THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION. IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FORTY FOUR PRECIADO.
CENTER BRADFORD LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MAKES TOTALING TWO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DADDY GRAY
WELL WITH UFCW WESTERN PLATE
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
TWO FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE WE WERE TRYING TO FIFTY
FOUR AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS OUT ON THOSE LEASE FOR
PLAYING YOU CVA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
YEAH THIS IS SERRA ARMSTRONG
DIRECTOR OF INDUSTRY AFFAIRS
FOR AMERICANS FOR STATE ACTORS
THE NATION'S OLDEST AND LARGEST.
PATIENT ORGANIZATION WHICH
STANDING STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS ARE CUED UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- SO I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION-
IS ON THE PHONE LINES HERE IN
THE CAPITAL A RING ARE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MEMBERS SAY NINE
CENTER BRADFORD WE LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'LL- WRITE BUT THE
PROMOTION WITH THE BILL THAT
ARE ACTUAL LETTERS MOVE THE
BILL THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS IS
THAT CORRECT IS THAT CORRECT.
RIGHT SO THAT THE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. SB TWELVE FORTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
CENTER APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER
HI. USER I. CHAIN BY BEING AYE
ARCHULETA. LET AYE DODD DODD
AYE GALGIANI. I GALGIANI AYE
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA BYE BYE IN.
AND I WILK HI I MEASURE HAS
NINE MEASURES NINE BILLS ITSELF
GRADUATION CENTER PRACTICE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NEXT UP. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR STERN. CENTER STERN
HERE. AS WE AS WE TRY TO TRACK
DOWN SENATOR STERN- SENATOR
WILL GOING TO PRESENT PERCENT
OR MORE ON MORALES BILL HI THIS
IS FILE NUMBER NINE SB TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE. SENATOR WELLS
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING ABOUT
THE CENTER MORALE AND YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF CENTER
MORALE I'M PRESENTING SB TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE. THE SENATOR WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND HE ACCEPTS STATE
TECHNICAL MEN IN THE COMMITTEES-ANALYSIS. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
ALLOWED THE BUREAU SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES TO
AUTHORIZE LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS TO BE ORGANIZED
AS LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES
ALSO KNOWN AS LLC'S. THIS IS
THE SECOND SUNSET EXTENSION
SINCE AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT WAS
ENACTED SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
MOVES A SUNSET DATE FROM
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BUREAU SECURITY INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES THERE HAS BEEN NO
REPORTS RECEIPT OF INSURANCE
CLAIMS SINCE THE LAST SUNSET
EXTENSION. WITH ME TODAY'S
JERRY DESMOND REPRESENTING THE
SPONSOR THIS BILL THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A
LICENSE TO GET INCORPORATED. AS
WELL SO LEGISLATIVE CHECK THESE.
KOHLER K. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THERE IS
NO RICHARD OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR WELCOME A- THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD THAT LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR PLEASE SO
INDICATE COME ON UP THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN HI I'M FRANCE A
KILLER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSES THAT
SKATERS I'VE BEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR ALMOST
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS AND
PRESIDENT WE- STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE- OF. OF SPONSORED
THING IS AGO AND WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR I BOUGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. JERRY DOES RUN
ABOUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION THE LICENSE OF
INSTIGATORS ALSO IN SUPPORT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND TO
APPRECIATE THE TECHNICAL MEMBER
THE COMMITTEE IDENTIFIED TO
MAKE BILL BETTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN HIS BILL
HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I SEE
NO OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. IN TWENTY FORTY
COLDER NO ONE THERE SO WE'LL GO
TO THE TELEPHONE LINES IF
THERE'S ANYBODY OPERATOR THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON SB
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE BY MORALE IN
FAVOR PLEASE. THE GAS AND TO SO
INDICATE. TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR.
ZERO NOBODY IS KILLING US OKAY
VERY GOOD OF AN ASK ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE SO
INDICATE SIGNAL HANDS REYES
WHEN I GO TO TWENTY FORTY UNTIL
THERE WAS NO ONE THERE. TO GO
TO THE ARE. THE PHONE LINES
OPERATORS ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE IF YOU COULD ASK
HIM TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO. TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION ONE ZERO. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP IT WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. YEAH SEE NINE
NOVELETTE SENATOR WILL COMBAT
THE CENTER MORALE CLOSE AND
THEN WILL TAKE A MOTION RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
VERY GOOD SENATOR CHIANG HAS
MOVED THE BILL SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONE ON I AM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. RATIONS GLAZER HI.
USER I. CHAIN NINE. HANG
ARCHULETA. VIRTUAL OUT I'D DODD
ALL RIGHTS DODD AYE AYE
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL
LINE. WELL I LEYVA BY THE ABOUT
IPN RIGHT. AND I WILL CRY WELL
I HAS NINE VOTE FIVE BEDROOMS
OUT NINE ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL THANK YOU SENATOR MORALE
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OKAY NEXT
GONNA GO BACK TO LIVE FILE FOR
A HOT WELL. SENATOR STERN I SEE
IN THE ROOM WELCOME COME ON UP.
TWENTY MISTER CHAIR MORNING
MEMBERS. RISE RESENT SB TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHTY ALL TODAY. AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE IN AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS- THIS LEGISLATION IS
REALLY DESIGNED TO SET US UP.
IN A SITUATION WHERE THERE'S A
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
MADE EITHER THE STATE OR THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- THAT INVOLVES
PROJECTS RELATED TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY CLEAN ENERGY- AND A
VARIETY OF. CLIMATE CHANGE-
TECHNOLOGIES AS WELL AS- IN
STATE LOCAL PROJECTS WE ALREADY
HAVE SOME OF THESE AUTHORITIES
WITHIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE BRAIN
BANK AS IT IS- THERE'S A
HISTORY OF MAKING A LOAN
GUARANTEES AND ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF INTESTINE. OVER THE
LAST DECADE IN VARIOUS WATER
PROJECTS SCHOOL RETROFITS THE
IDEA HERE IS TO HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE WAY IN AND REALLY
SHAPE WHAT THIS FUND COULD BE
SO I'D WELCOME THE COMMITTEE'S
INPUT- THERE'S THINGS YOU DON'T
REALLY SEE IN THIS FRAMEWORK
THAT YOU THINK COULD BE
BROADENED- AREAS THAT YOU THINK
REQUIRE- DEEPER INVESTMENT IN
ATTENTION WE KNOW THAT CONGRESS
HAS YET TO REALLY ACT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT STIMULUS
RESPONSE BUT THAT COULD BE
COMING- AND I REALLY WANT THE
STATE TO JUST PREPARED. WE
OBVIOUSLY HELP THE HEROES ACT
PASSED YEP THERE'S SOME OTHER
OUTSIDE INFUSIONS OF CAPITAL
BUT I'D LIKE THE LEGISLATURE BE
PRIMED AND READY SHOULD ISSHIN
FUNDING ALL PRIVATE- I THINK
THIS VEHICLE COULD COULD WAS TO
PUT OUR FOOT PRINT ON THAT- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL-
ISN'T TURNER WHAT IS. FAVORITE
PLACE KATE. NO HAN. FOR ONE.
THE PHONE LINES IT ON THE PHONE
I WOULD LIKE TO TEST IN FAVOR
OF SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT SO AND
OP. THANK YOU LADIES AND- PRESS
ONE ZERO TO TEST OF IN. AND
LINES SEVEN YOUR OTP. GOOD
MORNING KIRK JOHNSON WITH THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON NEXT PLEASE.
LINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES WITH THE
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
THERE'S TWO QUEUING UP. AND
YOUR MIND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT. TO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AIR IN ORDER TO
GET TO THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT. VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTITIONS CUED UP AT
THIS TIME OR A VERY GOOD WE'RE
GONNA ASK IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND WILL CALL ON
YOU. THE CITY HAS. AND THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM TWO. FORTY GO TO
THE- TELEPHONE LINES OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ON THE LINE I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT. PLEASE SO
INDICATE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP SIR THANKS
OPERATOR WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR CHIANG HAS MOVED THE
BILL I'M A LET'S SENATOR STERN
CLOSE THANK YOU- MEMBERS OF THE
ONE LAST THING I WANT TO
MENTION IS THAT. WITHIN THE
STATE HAVE WE DO HAVE CERTAIN
AUTHORITIES- BUT OUR BUDGET
WILL BE LEAN THIS YEAR WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING TO OUTSIDE
CAPITAL THE MAX MAKES IT
FEASIBLE AND REALLY LEVERAGE
THAT CAPITAL WERE NOT GOING TO
BE IN AN AIR OF GRANTS ANYMORE
WE SAW THE- GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION. ON GET PRETTY MUCH
ZERO OUT. SO THE PROJECTS YOU
ALL CARE ABOUT ARE GOING TO BE
DE FUNDED IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET LEANER
SMARTER WITH OUR CAP. STRUCTURE
THANK YOU. THIS THAT LEVERAGE
TO GO TO. CAP TO REALLY TELL
THIS NEXT STAGE OF. OF THE
INVESTMENTS WE NEED WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. THANK
YOU CENTERS RUN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA I
APPRECIATE. YOU TRYING TO FIND
A ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE THIS
VERY IMPORTANT AREA- THAT WE
THERE. ARE WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPINION AND WE HAVE A- IT'S- IS
THE- AIR THAT WITH THE ADVENT
AS AS WE ARE HOPEFL THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MOVE THESE TYPES OF
THINGS FORWARD SO WITH THAT. WE
HAVE A MOTION CENTER CHIANG IF
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONE
ON SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATE. THE USER IT'S R.
I. CHANGE FIVE BEING AYE
ARCHULETA CHILLOUT I'D AYE DODD
AYE AYE GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE HILL NINE HILL AYE LEYVA
AYE BELIEVE THAT I CAN HI AND I
A WILK HI OKAY I MEASURE HAS
NINE VOTE BY BOTH THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN.OKAY
NEXT UP IN OUR MIND MEMBERS
THAT WE DO HAVE UNTIL TO STOP
THIRTY WHICH BY TO MEET IF WE
CAN'T WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
AND AS- WE WELCOME HER FRIEND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIRMAN CHIANG I WILL
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS. ACCORDING TO THE MOST
RECENT DATA. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. HEALTH
CALIFORNIAN AUTHORIZED MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CATS AND DOGS STATE RIGHT IN A
SINGLE YEAR. THIS BILL WILL TO
LIMITATIONS IN CURRENT LAWTHAT
PREVENTS MOST SHELTERS FROM
GIVING PROPER TREATMENT. PET
OWNERS CAN GIVE THEIR ANIMAL
OVER THE COUNTER MEDICATIONS
BUT STATE LAW CURRENTLY
PROHIBITS NON VETERINARY
MEDICAL. STAFF BEING ABLE TO DO
THE SAME. AT ME INSTEAD OF AN
ANIMAL KERR TO THE SHIP FLEET.
ON STAY. LEGAL AND TO USE THE
NIGHT I AM. BUT NOT EMPOWER TO
GIVE IT A FLEA PILL. THIS BILL
WILL EQUALIZE THE ABILITY FOR
ANIMAL SHELTER CARE TAKERS TO
PROVIDE FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ADD. WHAT DO YOU.
ARE OUT UNDER CURRENT LAW TO BE
FOR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR- OWN PETS. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ALLOW PROPERLY TRAINED
OFFICERS EMPLOYEES AND
VOLUNTEERS OF AN ANIMAL SHELTER
THE AUTHORITY TO ADMINISTER
OVER THE COUNTER OR
PRESCRIPTION VACCINATIONS. TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE WITHOUT
PRESENCE OF A VETERINARIAN. THE
PROPERLY TRAIN SHELTER STAFF
WILL ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PERFORM NECESSARY BASIC FIRST
AID WITHOUT THE PRESENCE OF A
VETERINARIAN WHEN THEY HAVE A
WRITTEN TREATMENT PLAN FROM THE
VETERINARIAN AND A WOUND CARE
PROTOCOL. IN PLACE TO TRACK THE
ARE PROVIDED. THIS ALL SO EXACT
APART FROM WHITES WHEN ENGAGE
IN THE SPACE ACTS OF VETERINARY
CARE THE SHELTERS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO MAIN RECORDS OF THE
CARE. DURING THE LAST RECESSION
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HOMES WERE
ABANDONED ABANDONING THEIR
ANIMALS AT ALARMING RATES. I'M
AFRAID HISTORY WILL BE
REPEATING ITSELF GIVEN THE
ESCALATING NUMBER OF EMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN AND THAT WITHOUT THIS
BILL EUTHANASIA. WILL BE THE
ONLY MEANS TO CAN COMMUNICATE
DISEASES IN ANIMALS AUTHOR AND
THAT COULD BE THE LAST RESORT.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THE
SHELTER. A TORY IF TO HELP
BRING THE NUMBER OF YOU I IS
THAT MOST AND THE PORT GOVERNOR
ISMS DESIRE TO CALIFORNIA A NO
KILL STATE. WITH ME TO IS JILL
TUCKER'S E. HOW CALIFORNIA
WELFARE. AND BRIAN CRINAN CHIEF
OF ANIMAL CARE AND CONTROL OF
THE SAN BERNARDINO DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AGAIN I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
AMENDMENTS FROM OUR STAFF AND
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. BETTER GALGIANI SO ONE
TOLL ON THE LINE WE HAD THE
MISTER JILL TUCKER AND MISTER
BRIAN CRONIN OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
HIS TUCKER MISTER KRONE PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JILL TUCKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION AND THE SHELTERS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE STRONGLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF THE ANIMAL
SHELTER FACILITY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE ABLE TO LOOK
AT THAT. FOR A MINUTE DUE TO
LACK OF FUNDING WILLING
VETERINARIANS AND OUTDATED.
DAHLE FOR PROOF THAT WITHOUT
HER TO CARRY VETERAN BOARD
CONTENDS THAT THE SHELTERS ARE
BREAKING THE LAW SHOULD BE
ADMINISTERED VACCINES AND FLEE
TREATMENTS AVAILABLE TO THE
AVERAGE. OVER THE- EACH STORE
I'M SUCH AS SHELTERS ARE
PERMITTED TO TAKE IN ANIMALS
AND YOU CAN I BUT THEY CANNOT
PROVIDE THE CORE VACCINES
NEEDED TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
TO BE ARMONK MUST CHANGE THE V.
M. B. IS NOW GOING OUT
REGULATIONS TO GOVERN THE CARE
OF ANIMALS IN SHELTERS WITH
YOU. ALSO BECAUSE SOMEBODY.
VERY OVERSIGHT THAT MERRY. FOR
MATCH TO PROVIDE EVEN THE MOST
BASIC CARE MISTER OF THE CUT
DISTRICT ACOSTA A SIGNIFICANT
UNFUNDED MANDATE AND MAY RESULT
IN SHELTER CLOSURES AND
SKYROCKETING EUTHANASIA WELL
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN RAISED IN
PREVIOUS FUND REVIEW IT CAN BE
RESOLVED AT A LEVEL BECAUSE THE
STATUTE DEFINES THE SCOPE AND
SOLDIERS DO NOT TECHNICALLY OWN
THE ANIMALS FURTHER
INTERLINKING DISCUSSION
OPPOSITION THE SOLUTION FOR TO
PUT FOR ENTIRELY UNREALISTIC.
THE SCHOOL YEARS WE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT DECISIVELY.
INTERNET OF THE REGULATION TO
ENSURE WE CAN LAWFULLY TREAT
ANIMALS THAT COME INTO OUR
SHELTERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CRONIN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRIAN
CRONIN MY SERVICE TREAT ANIMAL
CARE CONTROL FOR ASSEMBLY
MENDOCINO COUNTY THE COUNTY OF
SAN BERNARDINO WAS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
WHICH ALLOWS ANIMAL SHELTER TO
PROVIDE VACCINATIONS OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICATIONS ADMINISTER
FIRST AID CARRY OUT THEIR
INSTRUCTION WITHOUT THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF. IRAN ONE ONE
PIRATE CAME ABOUT VERY CRIMES
PERMIT WE CAN OF SAN BERN NO
VALUES THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF
VETERINARIANS SUPPORTING THE
OVERALL HEALTH SAFETY SHELTERED
BATHS HOWEVER THE ANIMAL
SHELTER SPACE NUMBER OF
OBSTACLES IN OBTAINING BUT
MERRY STOP. MANY SHELTERS
UNABLE TO HIRE. THE SCHOOL
RECORD FOR. ADDITIONAL SHELTER
UNABLE TO FIND ABOUT THEIR-
WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY OF
MAINTAINING A VETERINARY
PURPOSES PERMIT. THE COUNTY OF
SAN BERNARDINO CONTRACTS WAS
SIX ANIMAL SHELTERS TO PROVIDE
SERVICE IN REMOTE AREAS OF THE
COUNTY. 50% OF THOSE FACILITIES
ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN THE
VETERINARIAN WHO'S WILLING TO
APPLY FOR THE PREMISES PERMIT
OR SERVE AS A LICENSEE MANAGER
OF THOSE FACILITIES. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN ALLOWS
ANIMAL SHELTERS TO PROVIDE THE
NEEDED LIFESAVING VACCINATIONS
FIRST AID AND CARE. WITHIN THE
SHELL OR THEY FOR THE- CHAMBER
IN THE OKAY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
SEVEN AND ENCOURAGE THE TO
SUPPORT THE SLUDGE AS PRINCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CRONIN LIKE TO INVITE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO COME UP AND
GIVE THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. AND EDUCATION
SUPPORT. THE ONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. DON'T SEE ANY
HANDS UP ROOM TWENTY FORTY
UNTIL THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
IF THERE'S A PEOPLE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. FIND FAVORITE AT THE
THIRTEEN FORTY BY SENATOR
GALGIANI KIDS. PLEASE ASK THEM
TO SO INDICATE. PLEASE INDICATE
BY PRESSING ONE ZERO AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING TRACY RYAN ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE NINE
TO SIXTY THREE. NINE TWO SIX
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE. NOBODY
ELSE IS CUED UP SIR VERY GOOD
WILL GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION LIKE TO ASK ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
PLEASE SO INDICATE. DOES HE
INDICATION ANYONE IN ROOM THREE
FORTY WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
ASK. FEDERAL LIKE TO SPEAK IT.
SB THIRTY FORTY SEVEN FIVE
SENATOR PAUL JOTTED TO INDICATE.
AND PLEASE DO THAT BY PRESSING
ONE ZERO. AND WILL. GO HEAD HIT
ONE ZERO. WE WERE GOING TO
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO SIXTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRISTINA TO
CARL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE ASSOCIATION CURRENTLY HAS
AN OPPOSED POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. CDMA CAR WAS IN THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WORKED WITH
THE BMB FOR OVER FOUR YEARS ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A RICH
PACKAGE THAT THIS BILL. TO
IMPROVE. THE VMAS CONCERNED
THAT LAYS SHELTER STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS WOULD BE PERFORMING
VETERINARY MEDICINE. WITHOUT
VETERINARIAN OVERSIGHT IN
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY OF
CALIFORNIA SHELTERS. CDMA FEEL
THAT IS ESSENTIAL FOR SHELTERS
TO HAVE A CONTINUOUS
RELATIONSHIP WITH A
VETERINARIAN IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF SHELTER PETS. SENATOR
GALGIANI AND THE SPONSORS
HOSTED A LENGTHY CALL WITH CDMA
LAST WEEK AND FOLLOWING THAT
CALL A LIST TO FILL THE ON YOUR
STAFF AND YOU MISTER CHAIR WERE
ALL INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CURRENT. ALL OF US TO WORK
TOGETHER. BUT IT. H. LIKE GO
ALONG IN ADDRESSING SOME OF CB
A MAYES CONCERNS THEY APPEAR TO
TIGHTEN UP THE BILL NARROW ITS
FOCUS AND CLARIFY SEVERAL
ISSUES SUCH AS THE DRUGS TO BE
ADMINISTERED. THAT WERE
PROBLEMATIC AREAS FOR CDMA AND
WHAT WE CAN'T COMMIT TO READ
MOVING OUR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME BECAUSE OUR BOARD MUST
REVIEW THE LANGUAGE AND TAKE
FORMAL ACTION WE DO A SHEET. OF
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE GALGIANI
DURING A VERY TIGHT TIME FRAME
IN THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE WHICH IS
TESTIFY. IT'S TIME. THERE'S NO
OTHER PERSON PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS I'VE
CENTER HEALTH SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
TO A SENATOR GALGIANI I MEAN
THIS IS AN ACTUAL EXCELLENT AND
VERY THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO
THIS PROBLEM WE JUST ADOPTED ON
FRIDAY TWO SIX WILL HOLD CATS
KITTENS. A MOTION IT WAS FROM A
FULL THIRD. OF FACILITY FOSTER
OF FAMILY THAT- HANDLES THAT
AND IN A LOT OF THE CONCERN AND
THE REASON THAT THE FOSTER CARE
IS SO IMPORTANT. IS BECAUSE OF
THE FEAR. OF THESE ANIMALS
GOING TO THE SHELTERS AND THE
LACK OF. OF VETERINARY SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED IN THAT THE
COST TO THE- TO THE TO THE
SHELTERS IN THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE FACED BY THE SHELTERS AND
THE FEAR THAT THE ANIMALS
COMING. THE SHELTER AFTER THE
OPTION HAVE. PROBLEMS THAT ARE
TAKE. RELIGIOUS SO I APPRECIATE
THE BILL APPRECIATE THE WORK IS
BEING DONE FOR YOU. THE A
COMMUNITY DOESN'T IS A- GREEN
WITH YOU AND BEEN AND THAT THE
AREA THE AMENDMENTS TO YOU'VE
TAKEN GOAL OF WAY ALL SOME OF
THE ISSUES AND PROBLEMS WITH
THANK UP HAVE TO SUPPORT EVERY
MOVE IT'S TIME THANK YOU FOR
TELL SENATOR PAT. BUT I WANT
THANK SERGEI NINETY FOR HER
WORK ON THE BILL ACTION
QUESTION TO THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION CDMA.
THEORISTS ON THE LINE. THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE THIS THE LAST SPEAKER
PLEASE. THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION STILL ON THE LINE
PLEASE. OPERATOR POS SYSTEMS SO
INDICATE SO IN CASE THEY'RE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING THROUGH.
OPERATOR YES CAN YOU AND ASK IF
THE PERSON- WHO SPOKE
PREVIOUSLY IS STILL AVAILABLE
ON THE LINE FROM THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IF THEY'D
LIKE TO- BE AVAILABLE FOR A
QUESTION PLEASE. ABSOLUTELY
LATELY TO SIXTY WOULD YOU
PLEASE PRESS SO ONE ZERO ONE
ZERO AGAIN. ONE ZERO AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
THINK IT'S GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FIRST OF ALL- BUILD I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL BASICALLY
FOCUSES ON THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE THAT ACTUALLY NORMALLY A
PET OWNER WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
ON THEIR OWN. BUT BECAUSE THE
ANIMALS IN A SHELTER AND THE
SHELTER STAFF ARE NOT
TECHNICALLY OWNERS THAT DAY
COULD PERFORM BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT TECHNICALLY THE UPPERS BUT
YET IN NORMAL AND I GUESS AND
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES AND OWNER
WITHOUT SUPERVISION
VETERINARIAN WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SIDE EVEN SO. CLEAR
BY FROM YOUR FOR THE- SO THERE
TO SITUATE FROM YOUR- CERTAIN
AGREE WITH YOU THE- THAT WE
SHOULD TRY HAVE A VERY. YOU
KNOW RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
SHELTERS AND THEN MAYBE THE
SECOND QUESTION IS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY THAT
MAY THE SHELTERS TO HAVE
CHALLENGES THAT FINING VETS WHO
ARE WILLING TO. PLAY THAT ROLE
AND DAY ON THE MAYBE LIABILITY
ISSUES ARE THINGS THAT PREVENT
VETERINARIANS FROM DOING THAT.
BUT PERHAPS YOU CAN ALSO
ADDRESS- WHAT'S BEING DONE TO
ENSURE THAT SHELTERS THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO VETERINARIANS- IN
THAT ROLE BUT PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THE FIRST
QUESTION I ASKED THAT IN
RELATION TO THE TYPES OF
THINGS. THAT SHELTERS
TREATMENTS CHECK. SHELTER STAFF
WOULD BE ABLE TO. TODAY IN A
SHELTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS CHRISTINA TO CARL CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN'T THANK YOU
CRISTINA GO AHEAD. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
DOCTOR PAN REALLY APPRECIATE IT
I THINK THERE WAS SOME
CONFUSION ABOUTTHE- BROAD
APPLICATION OF THE BILL. I
THINK THE NON PRESCRIPTION
ELEMENT WILL BE- IF WE TIGHTEN
THAT UP THAT WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL TO CDMA. YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN THOUGH DOCTOR PAN- I
THINK WHERE- THE CDMA WOULD BE.
MORE COMFORTABLE IS IF THERE
WAS SOME APPROPRIATE TRAINING
FOR SHELTER STAFF I KNOW THE
SPONSORS ARE WORKING ON THAT
COMPONENT I KNOW THAT THE-
BEING ON THAT COMPONENT. A
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT YOU KNOW
AS A SPECIES SUCH AS BORDER
COLLIES COULD DIE IF GIVEN-
IVERMECTIN AND SO WE JUST WANT
TO BE CAREFUL- THAT PROPER
TRAINING AND PROTOCOLS HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE. ON YOUR
QUESTION WITH THE CHALLENGES
AND THE VETERINARIANS-
PERFORMING THIS ROLE. ALSO A
VERY GOOD QUESTION A CDMA HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH CAUGHT WHAT
TO TRY TO IDENTIFY. SOME
OPPORTUNITIES. YOU KNOW WHERE
ARE THE FAILURES IN TRYING TO
RECRUIT AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY CAN BE HELPFUL. IN
THAT RESPECT THEY ARE DOING
THAT I THINK THE LIABILITIES
THAT IS A VERY BIG ISSUE IN MAY
THE BILL BEFORE WE CAN CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE THAT. PUTTING YOUR
NAME ON THE PREMISE THAT AND
THEN YOU NOT BE THERE ALL OF
THE TIME BECAUSE SOME OF THE
THINGS ARE OCCURRING UNDER
DIRECTOR INTER. VISION BETTER
ANY. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT ANSWER I
DO YAH I THINK THAT'S OUR
GALGIANI- I APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING WITH. DEFENDER
ASSOCIATION KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IS THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE PETS. AND IT
WOULD DETER. PROTECTING THE
SHELTERS BUT ALSO BE SURE THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE OTHER OPTIONS
OTHER THAN YOU I SING THESE
PETS. I'M SORRY PLEASE TO. BELL
BUT THE TIME THAT WOULD YOU TO
WORK AT THE VET. MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
MAKING PROGRESS AND THEY HAVE
TO GO BACK TO LEADERSHIP AS
WELL WITH TAKING THESE
AMENDMENTS CELL. AGAIN
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD SENATOR PAN.
AREA ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS LET ME
YET BEFORE I GO TO SENATOR
GALGIANI FOR CLOSE LET ME JUST
SAY THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI
AND THE FOLKS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH. ADVANCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL I'M I'M GLAD
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT A
LOT OF THE ISSUES- PRIOR TO THE
HEARING TODAY WITH THE
WONDERFUL CALIFORNIA VETERANS
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO
CERTAINLY THANK A LYSIS OVER
FOR MY STAFF AND ANSWER A MASON
AND OTHER TO OF WORK TO YOUR
OFFICE TO THIS BILL THE TAPE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING.
SUCH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I
WILL. IN THE AREA OF TRAINING
FOR STATE AND SHELTER THAT
YOU'RE COMMITMENT TO WORK. WITH
ALL. AS WE TRY TO. NEAR THE-
THAT WERE IN THE BILL AND ONE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY SENATOR
GALGIANI. CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP AND THE
HELP FROM YOUR STAFF. I WAS A
FOSTER PARENT FOR THE SPCA AND
STOCKTON PRIOR TO BEYOND BEING
ELECTED AND FOSTERED. MORE THAN
A HUNDRED CATS AND IN SIN
SOUGHT HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE
WITH. WORKING IN A RELATIONSHIP
WITH A VETERINARIAN THAT WAS
ASSIGNED TO WORK WITH OUR-
COOLEY. AT A SOMEONE WHO IS. A
PARENT CREATED. ADAM FOR. SAID
AN RING WERE AND OTHER THINGS.
TO PREVENT THEIR YOUTH AND AS
ATION BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT. HAD I NOT BEEN THERE IS A
FOSTER AND HAD SOMEONE ELSE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO BE THERE AS A
FOSTER. THE SHELTER STAFF WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PERFORM
THAT KIND OF CARE AND THEREFORE
THOSE ANIMALS WOULD HAVE BEEN
EUTHANIZED. SO I COMMIT AGAIN
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR RAJIDAE
I RECOGNIZE AN EMOTION FROM
SENATOR HILL TWO PASSES
APPENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
SECRETARY. ALL MMBERS I'D LIKE
TO REMIND YOU TO PLEASE TURN
YOUR MICROPHONE ON- SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR GLAZERS
BY. PLEASE I'D CHANGE.
ARCHULETA OUR VIRTUAL LEAD
OUTSIDE. AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI
AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL HI PHIL I
LEYVA HI LEVI IPN BY AN AYE
WILK HI. WILK I MEASURE HAS A-
THE MEASURE HAS EIGHT VOTE FOR
THAT THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
RESOLUTION CENTER GALGIANI
REMOVED TO ALASKA- ITEM ON THE
FILE ITEM. NUMBER ELEVEN SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THIS IS
OUR COMMITTEE BILL SENATOR
CHIANG OR VICE YOUR 20% CENTER
CHECK. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SHARE MEMBERS THIS IS OUR
ANNUAL COMMITTEE BILL TO CLEAN
UP THE CODE AND CONSOLIDATE
NUMBER OF NON CONTROVERSIAL
POSITIONS PROVISIONS. RELATED
TO REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONS UNDER THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE MOST
SUBSTANTIALLY THE BILL EXTENDS
A SUNSET DATE ON A NUMBER OF
BOARDS THAT WERE POISED FOR
SUNSET REVIEW THIS YEAR. DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT PROCESS
HAS BEEN POSTPONED UNTIL NEXT
YEAR. I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND ARE SIMPLY
TOWNER PARTS ENSURE THESE
BOARDS STILL RECEIVE THEIR OWN
COMPREHENSIVE. BY THE
LEGISLATURE. YEAH WHERE I
BOUGHT THE FOURTEENTH FOR THANK
YOU SENATOR CHIANG ANYONE HERE
IN THE- HEARING ROOM WITH THE
TESTIFIED FOR THIS PLEASE. MY
DRAMATIC WITH THE- STATE
LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. I SIGNAL FOR
THEIR HANDS UP WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY UNTIL NO ONE IS
THERE. WHO ARE THE PHONE LINESOPERATOR COULD YOU ASK IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
FAVOR THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE
SO INDICATE. I'M ON THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. TO
TESTIFY AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP VERY GOOD
I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IF THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
SO INDICATE. SIGNAL SEVEN NO
ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR THAT WOULD LIKE
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE.
OF THE DAY PLEASE INDICATE.
PLEASE INDICATE PRESSING ONE
ZERO TO. SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION
ONE ZERO POLICE. NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEE NINE I HEARD
CENTER LEYVA MOVING THE BILL
CENTER CHIANG WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. AT THREE AND ASK FOR MY
VOTE VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THAT'S TO PASS SAID TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR MICROPHONES ARE ALL.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS GLAZER HI. USER
I. CHANGE. HI ARCHULETA. FOR TO
LET AYE DODD ALL RIGHT DODD AYE
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL
BY HILL AYE LEYVA BY FIVE NIGHT
AND I WILL CRY WILK I MEASURE
HAS NEITHER THE MEASURE IS OUT
NINE ZERO TO THANK AT THE
OPERATOR THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
WONDERFUL TODAY- WASN'T EASY
BUT WE APPRECIATE ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK I DON'T THINK I GOT YOUR
FIRST NAME BUT- DROP. BUT THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
AT THE SERGEANTS EVERYBODY WHO
HELPED PREPARE THE COMMITTEE
FOR. THE GOOD WORK TODAY
CERTAINLY THE STAFF OF BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS SURVEY CENTER
TEAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S PUBLIC HEARING IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED
TODAY. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING AT THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AS IT ON
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMONSENSE
ARE IMPORTANT US. INCLUDE YOUR
TO IN THE OFFICIAL HERE RECORD
THANK YOU AGAIN AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
BUT TO MY COLLEAGUE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
BUSINESS PROFESSION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND WE ARE
OFFICIALLY. THANK YOU.